se passe bien le raid qui s'envoient
espérer que ça va bien se passer pour
les français on va remettre maxime et on
va on va se regarder des parties
ensemble alors tac tac tac carré akin up
mon fou rire qui marche un peu moins
bien aujourd'hui ça doit être d'avoir
trop de luminosité on va essayer de le
faire fonctionner là comme ça ça
s'apprend pas le soleil et donc bassine
grünfeld déjà c'est une page c'est une
bonne nouvelle en fait moi j'avais peur
de quelque chose de très théorique dans
la nage dorff
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne
chose en attendant essayer de choper la
bonne came voilà elle est là la cam de
maxime ont là comme ça on est en plan
fixe sur max recalés mon fond vert avec
le soleil qui rentrent hop comme ça il
fonctionne aussi
et donc là grünfeld il tombait un bon là
du coup pour le mans c'est très
théorique ça peut faire une turbo droit
aussi à ça m'étonnerait mais c'est vrai
que cariat kid maintenant étant un
joueur âgé quasiment envie de dire en
pré retraite n'est pas vraiment
retraités mais il est plus non plus à à
200% impliqué dans les échecs dont qui a
réussi un monde où il veut juste faire
un nul à les jouer des rapides parce que
ça le fait chier en fait c'est c'est
dans le domaine du possible
c'est réellement dans le domaine du
possible
on verra bien mais c'est dans le domaine
du possible
je vais laisser la théorie se dérouler
parce que là je crois que c'est là qu'il
peut y avoir l'avoir bande de nuls ils
peuvent faire la variante 2 turbos nuls
en dix minutes 1 on n'a pas les temps
alors si est-ce qu'ils sont pas affichés
ci s'ils sont à gauche
est-ce que c'est là la variante 2 turbos
il attend d'avoir essayé de retrouver
alors je suis sûr que c'est là elle
marche comment déjà est ce que c'est le
tour prend bessette vous prend f3 vous
prend f3 fou prend des quatre fous b4
pour des 8
un cavalier à 6 vous prend aux sept
tours à ses 8 ans est pas allé pas comme
ça l'a vraiment de drôles même si ça
aussi c'est une langue de drouot en vrai
ça aussi ça fait une turbo d'euros et
celle à laquelle je pense c'est pas
celle là pour prendre cette ouais ça va
faire nul en dix minutes ça la partie va
être terminé instantanément ouais ouais
alors ça on va l'avoir
ouais ouais c'est ça ça c'est la round 2
turbos d'euros ça va durer ça va durer
trois minutes
je vous avais dit un de parier sur le
nom maxime va-t-il gagner les punto ce
qu'ils vont partir immédiatement
c'est vers caraquet
un quine des prêts comme unis c'est un
genre pré retraités en fait un fin il
s'en fout il devait pas avoir d'idées
dans les ouvertures il envoie ça et
voilà quoi pourquoi jouer bon pourquoi
pas en fait
pourquoi pas sur les foules point f2 il
y avait tout le temps tourcoing f21 qui
couvrait tout assez saccadée 3 fou prend
des quatre qui éprouve encore j'essaie
tour 17 et c'est drôle ok ok partie
terminée bon ben si baky taryn aussi
vite on pourra voir le stream le plus
court de l'histoire à les bacs et une
turbo droit aussi et je vais plomb c'est
ça peut me faire ma journée ça mais
voilà la partie est déjà terminée c'est
pour ça que les parties longue phase on
a souvent parlé mais les parties longues
les matches comme ça qui dure des jours
avec un spectacle qui dure trois minutes
alors là mais j'ai absolument rien
contre les joueurs mais alors à dix
mille pour cent parce que de toute façon
parce que de toute façon là c'est un
format coupe ces éliminatoires
il enlève rien à personne donc là j'ai
héros malheur 0 même pas une once de
pourcentage contre cariat quines avec
les blancs qui a rien tenté la même dans
un tournoi privé fermer sa mort est
saoulé mais là dans un tournoi officiel
avec en jeu en 1 contre 1 en match j'ai
absolument rien contre cariat king qui a
fait sept nuls mais alors 0% quoi rien
du tout du tout du tout j'ai rien du
tout du coup du tout contre cardiaque
parce qu'il a fait le job
il pense qu'il doit l'en rapide il en a
rien à [ __ ] en fait un très clairement
il s'en fout complètement
il veut aller jouer les rapides salsoul
mais bon il a le droit c'est un format
coupe ça c'est voilà c'est c'est le truc
est comme ça après ce serait bien un
jour pour pour créer la rippe des échecs
qu'on se pose la question des formats
qu'on fait c'est toujours pareil mais en
soi
en soit j'ai absolument rien contre ça
entre temps canon erreur de transmission
est rare de transmission non non ça
c'est pas possible
la soie erreur de transmission soit
juruna fait non ça c'est impossible
ça c'est impossible
ces cavaliers b3 faut aussi ça la partie
la partie c'est ça je vous annonce mais
bon il peut pas avoir fait cavalier 6 ou
alors il a pété un plomb il est devenu
complètement fou mais il aurait déjà
abandonné en fait
enfin possible après il ya un monde
il ya un monde où ça existe en fait il
ya un monde où ça existe ya forcément un
univers quelque part où ça s'est passé
comme ça après c'est partout pareil sur
tous les sites tâches entre un check
follow chess donc c'est un bug échiquier
mais ceccarelli b3 le coin après pour le
moment on peut pas regarder la partir
donc on va attendre
bonne entame
am de max ouais elle sera pas changée et
mis sur baky un jour assure là c'est
magnus
là c'est toujours celui de leurs chants
clan delà c'est maxime est là en fait
elles marchent pas ok donc on a déjà
plus de came rentable ce live search est
comme terrible prost perdre de temps
quoi
abbas est parfait pour maximin
un petit tweet pour maxime
je mets le petit tweet tranquille
on va attendre d'avoir les coûts pour le
mans peut rien dire rien a commenté on
va attendre
le petit tweet qui est parti et merci du
coup à tous d'être là pour suivre cette
magnifique journée on va déjà envoyé une
pub en histoire de se mettre bien la
petite pub qui va partir façon il se
passèrent repas sur bitume
on va peut-être ainsi sa joue un petit
peu mais non là ça turbo d'euros moi je
suis content and ceinture bodereau prêt
serait bien d'en avoir deux de turbo
d'euros double turbo d'euros ce serait
parfait en fait petit cube d'entrée
façon-là ya problème de retransmission
peut pas avoir les parties donc enfin la
seule partie qui nous intéresse ça on
peut pas car la scène et scipione co
c'est un bug scandale benoît toulon
dahlberg la gt partage sur le troisième
jour ouais c'est long
j'ai vu la partie du beauf makarov ouais
j'ai vu aussi l'élimination de double of
terrible on peut suivre un peu durcies
piano pourquoi pas ici piankov pour
éliminer le saumon proches jean michel
cadrage temps ils sont ils sont prend le
cadrage complètement rata docquois haut
c'est terrible ça tremble pour cadrer
les échecs quoi c'est pas possible
oh là là le cadrage mais complètement
rate ados quoi c'est pas possible il ay
la palestine dit kamal frérot
ces terres il n'arrive pas à cadrer
akrad est correctement la partie une
partie d'échecs quoi c'est magnifique
laurent s'agit mines et de retard et
maxime a déjà fait nulle part oui on
s'est tu es là tu en mode raw cinq
minutes de jeu et les a mis cinq minutes
de jeu
je vis sur l'a2 égal ce cadrage ray
c'est beau la le gros plan sur magnus
ont plan sur les six pieds n'co est ce
qu'il n'est pas beau gosse celui ci
prennent qu'aux non en sérieusement
parlons sérieusement est-ce qu'on n'a
pas à faire un beau gosse là en vrai de
vrai si on pas si on parle très
sérieusement
non mais en vrai de vrai ce que c'est
pas c'est pas un peu le beau gosse des
échecs en vrai non messieurs on parle en
vrai on se parle très sérieusement entre
nous franchement j'ai envie de dire deux
ou fin j'ai envie de dire c'est le beau
gosse des échecs
non mais clairement il a 14 ans il a 20
ans je crois non mais très très
sérieusement j'en suis en discussion
très sérieuse entre nous il est pas
genre beau gosse de ouf et il est pas en
train de dire à magnus je suis plus
beaux gosses que toi excellence à l'ail
du rox pas très gentil vallée excellente
il a 19 ans et nommé de ouf en fait en
vrai en vrai franchement s'il réussit et
que et qui commence à gagner et où il va
être mis en avant 2 ou fin il pourra
voir des contrats de pub et où un nom
mais dont on devrait devrait genre en
deux genres notre hall genre notre holt
a un gars comme ça champion du monde ça
nous donnerait tellement une bonne image
en vrai de vrai aurais-tu cornette oui
bon pain et si bien qu il peut être
champion du monde doit théoriquement en
vrai peut faire du mannequinat un
sérieux pour l'image des échecs ça peut
être pas mal hein car si charismatique
nos envies en vrai papa pas tant que ça
un peu maintenant qu'il est champion du
monde mais moi je les ai déjà vu avant
qu'il soit champion du monde
le problème c'est qu'ils marchent
bizarrement je pense qu'il a peut-être
corriger mais sa manière de marcher été
assez étrange
non mais
marchand cavaliers vrai il marche un peu
un peu bizarrement elle est une démarche
un peu un peu bizarre
mais à l'ail symbian comme moi je dis on
est sur du beau gosse de quand même
assez qualitatif en faisant un peu non
vous sent pas tous d'accord
à partie de baky sur parvenu à six est
revenu avant alors c'était quoi du coup
on va pouvoir un peu se pencher là
dessus donc c'était toujours son père et
fils qui est ici 6e f3 chez pas qu'on
s'appelle sicilienne classique peut-être
on en vend deux fois non je trouvais
scipione qu au dessus de vente forrest
quand même
jeune comme moi aussi j'ai apprécié qu
il al air je sais pas il a l'air cool
tchatat les gens qui écrivent ou
franchement et si bien qu'au beau gosse
diouf arrêter de faire vos rageusement
mais complètement en fait un côté gendre
idéal qui aurait pu être égérie kinder
mais complètement mais complètement nan
nan il est dans un régime hyper
intéressant une naturelle surtout aouina
naturel en plus bien sûr naturel non
mais robin side genre toi qui es modo
beau gosse ou pas vos gosses discipline
qu à lyon on prend le modo le modo va
trancher
et en plus c'est un dea en vrai
complètement la classe mais tu vas en
plus c'est un vrai débat parce que
honnêtement tu as un gars comme ça
qu'ils qui commence un peu à marcher
tout je suis complètement sûr avec la
rive des échecs
il ya des il ya des marques ya des trucs
qui s'intéressent à lui au niveau de la
mode etc
je le vois trop faire de la pub pour des
jeans ou des trucs comme ça
carlson en vrai il s'est amélioré et de
base il n'était pas beau gosse mais
c'est vrai qu'il s'agit d'améliorer son
image mais oui je pense naturellement en
fait beau gosse non mais c'est un vrai
débat sur les échecs en fait vous rendez
pas compte
le mec sur l'interweb l'on sait pas qui
c'est y est nulle table
il était mannequin nu non il n'a pas été
maltraité rien du tout amusant mais
vraiment magnus non j'ai vu en vrai
franchement non mais mais mais alors pas
du tout magnus pas du tout il a enfin
fait spitler si vous êtes vous êtes
matrix et parce qu'il est champion du
monde n'en vrai pas du tout arrive aussi
à baky dans le vote on est perdus les
gars est mais bon c'est baky kimo moi
aussi je vois de baky non mais si tu
mets plus beau des beaux gosses et que
tu m'aies baky dans le vote évidemment
pas qui va gagner enfin qui peut lutter
avec baky qua non mais giroud d'en
avancer à rien ouais non ariane tard il
est vrai mais rien ne tarit pas assez
fort l'on parle de gens qui peuvent
devenir champions du monde donc oui bah
qui met bas qui bat qu'il a il a un et
six pieds de caudan dans chaque doigt de
pied quoi magny soit il a travaillé son
image c'est ça et il a bien fait
d'ailleurs pour la peine
y'a pas gestion douce avec les prendrait
5 alors c'est vrai mais ça c'est la
règle où tu as le droit de jouer deux
fois là en même temps si bas qu'ils
jouent deux fois en même temps il peut
avoir une position gagnante après sur la
place de fou cet effet qui prend des
cinq puis on prend des 5 et damas cinq
échecs il y avait jusqu'à prend 1,5 en
fait j'avais pas vu de base
leleu que le l'idée n'était même pas
venu à l'esprit en fait c'est pour dire
à quel point on n'y pensait pas
le zoom est quand même très qualitatif
là j'adore jean-michel cadrage si david
good enough au cadrage
[Musique]
les plans à la cam ils sont
exceptionnels franchement pourrait faire
un live on commente les caméras enfin
c'est du très haut niveau
bon là bas qui on va laisser un peu
avancé 1 mais ça tourne autour de la
case dessin un truc c'est que kébé 3 et
pas très bien placé je pense que ça va
être cool pour baky faut pas qu'il ait
le temps de faire un cahier de cavaliers
de carolis et 3g pas trop ouais en plus
y'a un truc bien c'est quand même le
maître le fou angers 5 pour fou
progressiste mais si tu pouvais pas à
cause de cas et prend des 5
on sait à quel point cette donc du coup
en vrai le foot doit venir en a trois
qui va pouvoir rock ça m'a l'air plutôt
cool
visuellement après ta phu prend des cinq
aussi peut-être eu des cavaliers b4 ça
doit être théorie qu'un sa c4 et ça ça
doit jouer
d'ailleurs ça doit être ça la ligne
critique en fait en vrai ça peut
ressembler un peu au chevet ch
les nouvelles variantes avec la réalité
sinko
dans cas
on va laisser la théorie se déroulèrent
las aussi ouais mais en vrai nom en fait
j'ai cipn que je n'ai jamais vu en vrai
par contre donc je peux pas dire le truc
c'est que c'est vrai mais ici viennent
quand je l'écouté en interview le truc
c'est que j'ai écouté ses interviews en
russe il s'exprime assez bien aussi
genre car yakine en fait il sait pas
parler c'est terrible et si piankov je
dois dire qu'il s'exprime bien
scipione qu il s'exprime très bien il
arrive à un genre de charisme naturel
qui avait pas forcément car le scène
avant de devenir champion du monde
on vous dit karine béguin
c'est vrai mais tu as des gens qui
bégaye dans une langue étrangère mais
qui n'égale pas dans leur langue natale
c'est pas le cas de cariatides rôle
bâtard c'était matin table
pourquoi en russe et scipione qu'à basse
parce qu'en fait quand au napa dax
anthony qui se prononce en trop et a
donc ils doivent prononcer ici pnk
messénie honey honey honey à c'est un
genre de truc entre les deux la route
c'est curieux j'ai du mal à le faire
mais seuil et déjà c'est pas ici peine
comme essayer si pierre quoi yes i
pianca bonjour et discipline qu quand
même en russe à atteindre l'ukrainien en
fait on court je demanderai aliéna ce
soir
nv elle résonne t-il en anglais en
français ou en anglais pense est parti
quand as tu penses dans quelle langue
api looping alors tu penses que maximise
parlant lui en veut pas lui même en
anglais ou en français
un mariage qui na waie mais parce qu'en
fait gare yatch qui n'a pourquoi
gharyane china parce que gary hachey ça
veut dire brûlant mobile sur deux du
coup en fait le mot gare yatch effet que
tu vas dire gharyane jeu qui m'a mais
après tu vas différents accents russes
tata des gens qui disent gorria tx qui
n'a
marat safin hispano sportif russe le
plus beau gosse all time ouais possible
possible après marat safin il était
enfin il est russe bien sûr mais il
devait être il n'était pas ta part vient
pas du tatarstan
d'après ces russes quand même hein
après il est en dessous de baky un safin
ça fait trois mois une moscou star
parraine c'est vrai ça se voit au typage
peut il est tard mais bon le tatarstan
et en russie et le tennisman russe aussi
le grand serveur tu parles de rachat nov
mais je crois crash à nos fils et
arménien c'est bien ici ici pierre k way
du coup il le prononce comme ça à son
nom il aurait fallu fleurs et feuilles
que je le lise en cyrillique
je me suis dit mon prof de russe en
seconde qui me disait qu'en russie il
n'ya pas d'accent ni de différences
régionales
ils étaient russes le prof ou pas ce que
je sais pas s'ils voient la taille de la
russie mais même si à pas d'accent très
marquée il ya des accents quand même par
rapport à la taille du pays seraient qui
a pas énormément d'accent mais bon j'ai
quand même des différences de
prononciation ça fait quand même 58 fois
la france donc le bon bout d'un moment
mais bon bout d'un moment c'est complet
que ce soit
pour la peine lui dis que je dirais pas
il ya des expressions différentes et ça
parle un peu différemment et a plus une
intonation qu'un accent après dans le
caucase ils ont ils ont pas mal
d'absents les gens et pourtant c'est pas
loin de moscou les les gens à l'est je
sais pas trop
quand ils ont la taille de la france
alors ça dépend si tu prends la france
avec les pays outre-mer le match du 92
monde façon 26 fois la france en gros tu
as un truc c'est un grain de sable est à
l'autre ça rochet quoi
un petit accent je crois pas non
et entre les territoires outre-mer pour
être précis aramis ferdinand mais si tu
veux reprendre tous les maux de
quelqu'un qui stream tu peux tu peux
t'amuser c'est facile sur 50 heures de
live par semaine
donc on est le plateau que généralement
on attend la fin de l'ouverture pour toi
le plateau là on attend c'est
théoriquement c'est fou prend des 5
on attend un peu que l'ouverture se
décante on connaît bien les enjeux sa
tente sur la casse des 5 mais le truc
c'est qu'il va y avoir des changements
de structure probablement et que ça va
changer les enjeux stratégiques dont il
faut il faut qu'on attende la fin de
l'ouverture pas le choix
et houba qui il à sotchi essayez de le
choper sur une cam
entre la france d'outre-mer vont peu
importe sa trente fois c'est déjà
beaucoup quand même
enfin actuellement trente fois peut-être
qu'on passera bientôt à 58,1 attention
hein
il ne faut pas crier victoire trop vite
j'anticipe un évident il a fait rock ok
j'ai bien fait de pas me plonger dans
l'analyse il a fait rock à leur rock
il va falloir envoyer la turbine je
pense pour aller voir
j'avais c'était plutôt fondées cinq ici
falloir allumé la turbine
elle est franchement dommage cette rime
avec les mandats par deux cars yakine
rabat il a voulu donner les points
chaîne à ceux qui ont voté dont je vous
avais dit que c'était free money je
donne des conseils aux gens sur les
prédictions
heureusement que j'étais là heureusement
que j'étais là pour les prés d'un parce
que sinon ça allez ça allait pas gagné 1
c'est sûr que ça lui sur votre groupe
est évident
il n'y avait rien de plus évident que ça
mettre un peu de théorie voir un peu ce
que ça donne jusque là nul pour garde
par exemple vous avez expliqué c'est
juste que les deux joueurs connaissent
et une variante qui permet aux blancs de
force et au blanc au fait de forcer la
nul contre la green fees n'est plus j'ai
tout de suite directe est plutôt content
du choix d'ouverture
il ya encore beaucoup de parties on va
voir mais comme prévu 1 c'est surtout
demain que ça va être intéressant
en fait on essaye d'un peu hype et tout
mais en vérité hier quand ça s'est fini
qu'on a discuté avec avec fab
enfin moi c'est le scénario que
j'attendais pour aujourd'hui un jeu
c'est le scénario que que j'attendais
aujourd'hui quand même et j'espère et
une nulle rapide de baky aussi
on va attendre encore plus de parties
que je ne le pensais on va laisser la
théorie ce se finira karine sera
dangereux au départage très dangereux
mais maxime favori à mon avis surtout
après la partie d'aujourd'hui c'est quoi
l'intérêt de faire cas de faire mieux
avec les blancs comme je l'expliquais
plutôt cariat keynes un joueur
pré-retraités cette justice s'en fout en
fait il n'a pas trop d'idée ce qu'ont
les ouvertures de maxime il a peut-être
une petite idée mais qui veut garder en
rapide parce que c'est une idée pratique
et veut pas laisser le temps à maxime de
trouver sur l'échiquier une défense et
donc il s'en fout en fait pourquoi pré
retraités parce qu'il ya d'autres choses
à faire en fait il s'en fout il allait
il a d'autres d'autres projets plus
lucratifs et du coup et josé chacun peut
à larache quoi
ces victoires quand je sors de zagreb
même veille va être serein pour le
départage oui et non la ga des pins oui
parce que parce que oui parce qu'il est
fort mais d'un autre côté il est passé
très proche de l'élimination contre par
avion quand même hein c'était quasiment
à 50 50
c'est de toute façon cccd partage
t'envoie une pièce j'ai envie de dire
c'est c'est difficile de dire c'est sûr
qu'il va gagner l'est beaucoup plus fort
ça joue tellement à rien une partie
d'échecs
servi de gm de ne pas avoir battu magnus
je crois mais comme j'avais delight
chimie est plus ou moins en place par
poutine dans des commissions spéciales
russes machin et où il a plein de
contrats de pub le gars est blindé il
s'en fout tu voit très clairement enfin
il y aurait bien aimé être champion du
monde mais il n'a plus envie de refaire
les efforts en partant de zéro pour se
requalifier aux candidats les regagner
etc
il a joué à siegco je vois encore
théorique n'est plus trop ça a l'air
d'être assez bien
donc
caillé aussi balèze va peut-être qu'il
est bien préparé avec les noirs pour pas
perdre et qu'avec les blancs quand il
compte du top niveau c'est beaucoup plus
dur de ce que je vous disais hier si
vous écoutez les live je vous ai dit que
c'était beaucoup plus facile de balancer
une prépa avec les noirs genre s'enlever
que la rage de craca yakine c'est un
niveau non le niveau de karuïa keynes un
niveau que 100% du chat n'inclut menthe
n'atteindra jamais hein parce que les
grands joueurs russes ont connu du grand
public car les kings léconi ouais c'est
le seul dans les joueurs actuels qui est
vraiment connu parce que comme je disais
un peu proche de vlad quoi de vlad torse
nu sur le cavalier 1 jusqu'au niveau
très clairement oui
la sport c'est plus un joueur d'échecs
le match du 92 et il jouit plutôt d'une
mauvaise image en russie pour des
raisons évidentes
pas bien sûre et plus connue mais c'est
plus un joueur d'échecs non plus dans
les joueurs qui jouent encore un peu
actuellement car yakine ça va être le
plus connu est la prise et le niveau à
larache à bas que le niveau à l'arraché
plus fort que 100% du chat aussi car
yakine en fait car yakine à larache le
seul qui peut être plus fort que lui en
france cmv elle y avait aucun autre
joueur qui peut être plus fort en france
que car yakine à larache
dans 15
on a enfin bas qui a là bas qui arrache
non objectivement cariat qui n'est plus
fort que baky et bakary qui n'a la rage
qui jouent encore 2007 30 août 2007 40 1
qu'il est censé être plus fort que baky
encore guy roux en sueur faut qu'ils
progressent fuir ou djigui francophones
en plus j'ai pas dis français de mémoire
on peut dire que fuir ou des
francophones ça me sauf peut-être j'ai
dit français alors phil rogers aus ici
francophones que maxime jeudi en france
du coup à fuir ou déjà aussi terrible
valvidia francophone j'ai hésité en plus
shankland pied de la 500 voiliers à
cuatro en fait s'en prendre aux
cavaliers décidé de se prendre la case
des quatre est de faire du damas un coup
dame b 6 on va voir j'ai envie de
laisser encore quelques courses que
c'est la théorie à fond à sa nature à
fausser pas à fond
qui connaissent plus trop d'amd 2 à 4
allée des cas comme je vous le disais
c'est l'idée il reprend pions prend
cavaliers prendra me prend dame prend
écarts et les 17 mai au 17 juin un truc
comme ça où le fou où les noirs ont
donné un pion mais le foot case blanche
est mauvais
c'est jouer ce genre de position avec
l'activité tête qui avait 17 est pas le
plus fort ici parce que des ventes de
drouot comme ça d'aujourd'hui se joue en
match pour devenir champion du monde ça
peut arriver en toute fin de match gilou
peut-être toi c'est 8 à 3 b 3 des 5 vous
fera que ce genre de choses qui peuvent
arriver
je préfère les blancs
les coopérateurs des cinq mois dans
l'est vraiment qu'on a vu possible
désolé si j'ai un petit écart pour
répondre au chat sur czech comme c'est
un truc qui me qui me dérange un petit
un petit peu pour vous dire la vérité
pour rebondir rapidement et c'est parce
qu'ils veulent streamé et sur twitter et
sur être sur youtube donc au lieu
d'avoir un écart de 5 à 8 secondes
quatre à huit secondes habituellement
quand je le stream sur ma chaîne là j'ai
un écart de 25 secondes avec le chat
ce qui fait que parfois j'ai un petit
peu du mal à rebondir avec ce que vous
dites
désolé pour ça du coup mais c'était pour
expliquer des fois le le fait d'être un
peu à contretemps quoi
c'était juste pour expliquer un nom
plutôt vin mais bon c'est beaucoup plus
long que ce que je fais d'habitude
j'ai un peu à contretemps et je lis que
les commentaires du chat switch même si
je préfère ceux du tube et parce
qu'après c'est trop il ya trop de
messages peux pas je peux pas tout lire
et donc voila en gros l'idée 1c d'amd de
me demander de ces logis qui sont tu
apprendras quatre dames à 5 après tu
peux aussi faire flouer deux en fait
mais bon ça en vrai c'est assez logique
j'ai pas tu te développe également des
gens soutenant frankia je jouais je
jette un oeil mais je crois qu'il ya
personne en fait c'est juste pour
pénaliser le k-7 en fait ça ça peut être
dangereux par exemple
360 336 heures sur youtube ce qui est
pas si mal an après je viens d'apprendre
des cas direct non mais après si tu le
laisse en vie peut s'y accrocher comme
une moule à son rocher 1
la fouille de aussi fondamentalement
comme move à 4 crise et un hawkeye d2 et
qui a aidé cette qui haïssez 5 et puis
1,4 et à sécuriser la casse parce qu'il
ya plus de béco a trop
j'adore comme la la la cam régie en fait
c'est une régie là qui décident de
quelques à me mettre prend le travelling
prend le travelling deux frérots ouais
non là on est quand même on ne cale sur
une régie tellement qualitative
elle est fantastique la régie 1 c'est
jean michel a réagi avec jean-michel
cadrage quoi les frères les frères
jumeaux
les frères siamois il y en a un qui sait
pas cadrée et l'autre qui sait pas
mettre les plans intéressants à
peut-être qu'il a zéro plan de mai car
la régie en vrai en vrai le mec à la
régie va peut-être que des plans pour
avis sais pas quoi mettre mon oreille
fait que nous montrer chant clan des
îles font que de montrer champion d iler
ouais après après ouais franchement
franchement le gala registre est qu il a
le choix entre tellement de cabine
intéressante c'est ouf
il ya quand même beaucoup de public un
envoi pour pour cette coupe du monde
la salle est remplie un beaucoup de
ferveur côté supporters en russie ils
ont réussi à faire venir du monde pour
suivre ces partis en direct dans la
salle exceptionnelle exceptionnel
c'est notre préférée avec martirossian
moins beau gosse qui s'y tienne car non
aux eaux le cadrage chemise
en fait ils ou même d'une telle force
ils peuvent même port et dans l'est
c'est terrible
il s'est barré kwaï très beau conte et
des champs contrechamps maintenant
magnifique les calmes mais c'est dommage
qu'on ait pas baky quoi montrer nouba
qui en plus c'est un peu dommage qu'ils
ont nous ont montrés très longtemps la
partie française dans ce qu'ils
appellent le camion très très longtemps
de villers contre champions lors qu'ils
ont une cam sur leur échiquier
c'est qu'il a je reconnais pas ce que
serait pas c'est qui lui
ces faits d'as à 7 tab à 2
mais à celle
on n'a pas pris le bonne iranien c'est
jean-michel on n'a pas pris de bonnes
iranien c'est terrible
m
ce serait beau si vichy lie aux
candidats je suis restée complètement
nul enfin pour halo candidats évidemment
mais ce serait beau dehors un mec à
moins de 2006 aux candidats en vrai
venez on est pour les gars les plus les
moins forts quoi on cherche les nuls et
on espère qu'ils se qualifient donc on
met martirossian tabatabaei voilà ce
qu'on a deux nuls face à face donc on
peut pas être pour un joueur
par contre chant clando candidats
franchement c'est beau hein ah mais je
vous raconte maxime au prochain tour
mais on devrait avoir chante landau
candidats d'ailleurs j'ai bien aimé ce
qu'ali shankland il a dit dans une
interview si vous n'avez aucun talent
comme moi il n'y a pas d'autre choix que
de beaucoup travailler pour devenir 2700
échec ou un truc comme ça
traduction approximative mais en gros il
le dit lui-même qu'il est complètement
nulle courage alors en fait lui-même il
est au courant qu'il est nul quoi et
l'effort shankland non je le rappelle
une partie du show claude d'un gars sur
des quatre c'était je crois y patof il
avait fait à six il avait écrit en
commentaire de la partie en mode veille
jean-claude à part la théorie hier quoi
fin et du couchant clooney joue un truc
exceptionnel il avait joué ses quatre au
lieu de faire re 4 et de prendre le
centre quoi il avait fait ses quatre
éclairé et il avait perdu qu avec les
blancs c'est un terrain
d'être lucide dire evans est
complètement une nouvelle chasse un
complètement maximin mais c'est lui qui
l'a dit bon quant à aucun talent comme
moi par travailler t'as pas le choix
quoi vrai qu'on vous la face avec fabre
la partie qu'on trie pas top c'est
exceptionnel
mais du coup il assume complètement le
fait d'être nul est d'être un énorme
bosseur
du coup venez on est pour à part les
français on est pour shankland venez on
fait un vote
est-ce qu'on est risqué pour championde
à parler français à moins qu'ils tombent
sur maxime et qui au prochain tour mais
sinon venait 6 me chante landes ou pas
en tout cas on est pour lui maintenant
après malheureusement il sort au
prochain tour contre ndl
mais sinon il sort de zone et un petit
enjeu quoi
mais moi je respecte trop ça en fait
d'être conscient que tu es complètement
nul et que tu arrives à 2007 juste en
beauce encore une fois c'est un peu
comme favori face à un wawrinka ecoplus
java brincard le truc c'est qu'il c'est
un énorme bosseur mais en plus il a fini
à élaguer grand chelem méchant klaus a
quand même gagné championnats des états
unis
mais ouais ouais
kas est énorme bosseur sait il paraît
qu'ils bossaient mais c'est un truc de
ouf
mais disons que wawrinka de base c'est
pas un nadal c'est pas un djoko c'est
pas un fait des fabricants il censé être
un peu en dessous mais c'est un bosseur
de malades
baïla talent peut-être pour faire top 15
top 10 mondial de base mais il te fais
un truc où c'est le seul qui était pas
capable de battre les plus grands
joueurs de l'histoire
le taf a fait la différence là le
problème c'est que shankland
c'est un truc de ouf
brink à il paraît qu'il allait même le
soir gamin encore taper la balle contre
le mur pendant deux trois heures face et
je crois que c'est vraiment une brute de
travail de malade à wawrinka et son
niveau quand il était dans les grands
jours s'était passé le seul à pouvoir
nettoyer djokovic du cours quoi il y en
avoir des affaires va fêter glisse at il
fait on verra demain et et glissades
regarde encore temps et un regard dans
la gueule des gages il était
exceptionnel wawrinka barinka c'était
c'est ouf ce qu'il a réussi à faire
alors après il avait pas il avait plus
de talent que jean-claude mai
mais nadal et djoko ici mais tu sens que
de base ils sont au-dessus quoi déjà
très jeunes ils sont très forts wawrinka
tu sens que tu as et battu de ouf à un
petit coup de ike femmes ont peu importe
shankland c'est un génie
jaune qui sut après à 5,1
donc
assez génial envie de gerber à la fin du
live tous quoi
[ __ ] on ne doit renvoyer une petite
pub on va attendre tranquillement mais
petite pub de trois minutes un histoire
de seins se détendre un jeu d attaque
pour baky voilà ça va être très concret
un ca quatre quarts aile et des quatre
un peu l'idée du truc mais ça dépend
vraiment de ce que les blancs jouent on
va voir ce que pure ou nadal voit en
train façon il va être obligé de se
démasquer un moment où l'autre 1
mais 5 c'est beau c'est qu'à moi je suis
heureux en fait
henri iv a de bonnes chances se
qualifier pour les grands prix fidèles y
aura soit martin / wells what i've à
tabac ah oui et c'est pour ça qu'on est
pour shankland c'est pour que champion
d'aller au grand prix fidh ça y est j'ai
compris en fait on à fond pour shankland
en vrai ce serait tellement beau
champion de grand prix fidh il va
tellement bossé comme un malade pour
essayer de faire un résultat il va tout
donner quoi ah non c'est magnifique
remote shônen rech en cloud en mode
shonen
en plus il a son petit surnom lâche en
classe il a fait foot est roi alors fou
détroit honnêtement ce n'était pas dans
le daniel du tout je pensais plutôt
foods dans ces cas là parce que ça casse
la connexion avec des quatre le coup une
tête bizarre et en plus sûr qu'il ya des
scènes qui haïssez 5 on le touche
fou des droits je sais pas c'est une
tête bizarre
c'est une nouveauté ah ben ça m'étonne
pas le coup a une gueule bizarre le fou
pourquoi le pourquoi pas le mettre en e2
et laisser la colonne des ouverte
après c'est vrai que dans les cas où on
prend des 5es cure prend du plomb il est
mieux placé ça doit être ça leader je
vois pas une autre idée c'est en cas de
prise de reprendre deux mais on va pas
prendre en fait encore une pub bat à 6
minutes de pub toutes les heures
histoire de se mettre bien maxime il
plutôt intelligent pour empêcher growth
in forcé mais après il ya zéro avantage
j'étais en train d'arriver à ton
raisonnement petit à petit maxime mai
mais bon ça pas une belle tête il ya eu
un peu trop cligner des yeux
alors du coup c'est plus théorique est
ce qu'on peut faire ils envoyaient à
cuatro quand même en éclaireur
lecavalier ce qu'il a mal en d2 parce
que du coup maintenant que le fouet en
d3 on peut à il veut peut-être rebondir
comme ça ok du coup plutôt cavaliers c1
pour essayer de faire sens et sur qui a
validé quatre fous prend des quatre
quelque chose comme ça j'en prends des
quatre et on aurait il reviendra le
prendre avec cavaliers 2 qui a aidé 4
donc
foot est roi
cinéma qui en fait c'est désespérant
comment ça s'écrit caillé a complex
rebond il ya une double idée c'est quand
tu prends on reprend 2 e et g car et
lycéens qui avaient lieu deux avec cette
caste qui peut être belle tiendra pas
une touche sera it est complètement
je suis un prix pareil passe pas plus
ici piennes cas ici pianca
et à 4 qui avait laissé un à trois ans
nous propose oil alors on n'est pas
obligé de se précipiter un scan 3 il va
faire b3 fin il peut faire b3 à chaque
fois donc on peut se garder l'option
bon il ya des options à écouter ce que
cavaler b4 un coup je pense pas ça mais
pour peut-être prendre et prendre
ses gammes de pas qui ça c'est que moi
j'ai pas tout le temps la cam devant moi
ça si c'est la cam de baky mais ils
cadrent pas maquillée en plus c'est pure
honorer ces purs ou une en façade c'est
sûr c'est baky ouais ça et je veux
l'assumer en plus grand c'est baky baky
de dos
q rhône en fait ouais serre que le
presse quand on a sonné il est là en
numéro deux en fait
non il est pas mal baki
qui le filme et jean-michel régit les
pas en train de je comprends pourquoi
ils changent pas les calmes fixe puisque
de toute façon il bouge avec leur came
en fait du moment qu'ils bougent
regarder en fait cette carte là elle
pourrait bouger puisque les jean-michel
cadrage on les voit bien tournée est à
quel moment le gars il peut pas sauver
son trépied qui est devant la partie de
maxime et le déplacer vers bas qui en
fait je comprends pas moi y'a pas qui tu
dis femme va faire un tour tu as vu la
partie de maxime way regard bas qui
regardent comme il est beau regard comme
il est beau il est vraiment très beau
halak aurait il fait mal en europe sur
wii ne doit pas être bien en face un
regard défaillant et fabien aubat issue
à tout
ouais
bah oui que runje n'est pas bien
hoballah ça va cadrer baky là on est
bien
hoballah on est ébloui par la beauté du
président même de dos 1
on parlait des six pianos beau gosse web
et said bâ qui monte un peu bref voilà
mais bon c'est le sait le prêt après ans
et normal que ce soit au dessus 1 et 6
piennes qu il fait ce qu'il peut mais
rivaliser avec baky et complexe
il est pas il est pas bien il n'est pas
le regard regarder le pressent rôles de
beau gosse regardez-moi ça et il note
son coup et puis ruine qui joue tempo
terrible on va voir le coup arriver avec
jean-michel cadrage il n'a pas il n'a
pas eu le réflexe de faire un gros plan
sur les à cuatro donc il a attaqué le
quai je pense et qui avalise c ou no 1
qui des deux ça me paraît vraiment
bizarre avec le foot est roi
lorsqu'il a joué tempo et puis route
mais c'est peut-être c'est peut-être une
erreur mais je pense ce cavalier partie
ans et un quart est listé ou non rester
sur cetet il sait garder la casse de 2
ça va pas impressionner pas qu'ils
incarnaient les c1 je vous le dis tout
de suite on arrive à jouer bas qui il
est pas bien pu rhône
il est pas bien ce serait beau combat
qui datent des petits points
d'exclamation cpp sur sa feuille de
partie après ce avec les échiquiers sont
pas très beaux là pour pour cette
compétition vous avez remarqué en france
on se bat qui doit être déçu 1 quand tu
vois les échiquiers halfaya quelques
retrouve retrouva à jouer là dessus je
pense qu'il doit avoir des réunions à le
soir pour essayer de vendre
il ya quoi il ya deux cent cinquante six
parties en même temps au premier tour
entre le le mixte et les femmes ouais je
pense qu'il peut il peut essayer de de
faire une vente de 250 300 échiquier
halfaya car là dessus à mon avis il ya
moyen parce que là c'est vrai que ça
doit lui faire mal au coeur de jouer
avec un échiquier des pièces comme ça
ça me paraît quand même assez normal
hein
il a sa carte 8 au président de la fide
rabat mon avis a déjà des négociations
en cours sur les échiquiers peut-être
avec des pièces un peu custom mai mais à
quelque chose à faire après là je pense
est aujourd'hui peut-être son stagiaire
maxime sort moment qui fait qui fait des
stages maxime chane kaï chek qui était
venu me livrer quelques échiquier là il
avait un peu de mal au haut niveau
au niveau de la livraison du colis mais
peut-être qu'il a envoyé maxime du coup
pour pour aller pour aller faire
quelques négociations aujourd'hui un ca
expliquerait la nuit le rapide ça
expliquerait complètement la nuit le
rapid tête un accord qui a été passée
justement avec avec aria king qui est
proche proche de poutine et maxime du
cou qui en a peut-être profiter cet
aprem pour pour parler business 1 les
affaires sont les affaires
maxime qui a assuré à la livraison
l'alpha prime à l'alpha prime kit qui te
permettre d'avoir les livraisons
gratuites en illimité moins de 48 heures
chez toi
j'ai raté un exode de maxime son
contrôle antidopage bam et émettait un
copier coller un c'est dur je regardais
bas qui est aussi con voulez vous que je
regarde le chat quand il ya ba qui à
l'écran je peux pas voir le chat quand
je vois bas qui j'ai les yeux rivés sur
baky moi enfin j'ai même pas comment
vous réussissez à comment vous
réussissent à 'achat' est en fait assez
complexe voilà qu'est ce que je regarde
aussi a écrit cyrus et à baky quoi c'est
pas pour mais un pay sirius revient doit
payer sirius les amis pour pouvoir être
filmé en même temps que baki j'imaginais
le prix d'un tel sponso là à mon avis et
chéreau en à mon avis et chéreau
bien évidemment
dégagez contrôle antidopage s'était pas
arriver exceptionnel c'est beau ça ça
c'est beau ça c'est très beau
maquis qui lâche des tirs regard pour
stoner sarciaux il a fait le cavalier 17
et il s'est dit je veux cavalli ces
signes qu il est pas bien donc ça je
vous en ai parlé tout à l'heure
maintenant rock et peut-être car et dc5
donc il veut un peu joué contre le
cavalier c'est un cavalier e 2 après ce
qu'il a il aurait pas pu commencer par
cavalier c'est cette rock et se garder à
quatre leur faire fou j'ai cinq ici une
façon de cavaliers pas très bien placé
en b3 chief est prise prise disons non
c'est pas forcément le meilleur coup
mais le cavalier toute façon il va
repartir comme ça donc peut-être le
garder un peu plus longtemps b3 ce que
j'imagine c'est qui s'est dit que de
toute façon il allait chasser un jour et
qui voulait savoir si la lande et deux
points c'est un pense que c'est ça la
logique de baky après ouais
un fake un bain dans le chat c'est moi
ouais ouais y'a mvl chez slightly se
prend pour mvl ça fait ça fait des mois
que ça dure je n'ose pas lui dire il
m'écrit sur messenger et tous un truc de
ouf
vous pouvez l'écrire du coup bas qui va
suer à la fin de la partie à ma place et
oui il va suer bas qui il va aller faire
le contrôle
ça fait ça fait des mois que ces
nouvelles pièces dont on est obligé de
lui faire croire que c'est ma gueule de
laisser croire que c'est maxime quoi
à barrès et l'imposteur
celle en poster un hilali s'est même
créé une fausse chaîne twitch où il a
récupéré des vidéos de maxime pour les
maîtres et où c'est vraiment un truc de
ouf
c'est vraiment un truc de ouf petit rock
l'aurais je pense il doit partir ou pour
fo le match est fou j'ai cinq ans fait
pourquoi garder un mauvais fou n'est pas
fou j'ai think of web dos cavaliers
c'est sinko le ferait dans cet ordre là
j'ai l'impression que je regrette un peu
mon fou il est un peu mieux franchement
ça va pour baky ça vraiment moi je
prends les noirs un ici
bon alors beau gosse ou pas ici viennent
cas on reprend le débat tout à l'heure
en vrai longue de caméras est pas
terrible
peut-être qu'il refasse un peu peut-être
un hunter cattin peut-être fogo hunter 4
vrai
il n'y a pas débat méga beau gosse après
inférieur à baky en ce sens on a fait
fait pas tout à l'heure un
brender catella il existe à nancy
gownder cote honnêtement on n'est pas
bien
charismatique ah bah si c'est parce
qu'il n'a pas encore le titre ou deux
peut-être le de venir ici bas qui gôuter
cote
ouais mais en fait si baky koné de
retraite après ça devient trop
problématique il a fait bouger sinko bas
qui a pas de surprises encore là je vais
te dire le fou c'est sinkot bas qu'il
était attendu on connaît le loustic 1
dans le cas
manu si sûr
l'arceau thing vie dit on l'a pas encore
eu à la cam ce qu'il est éliminé
ou pas en vrai nom il joue encore ils
jouent contre du gharb ali mais ils
n'ont pas du tout passé sa partie vrai
qu'il est sympa vie dit il a un charisme
sympa en plus il a il dégage un truc
coup là
houphouet f2 ça c'était sûr ici j'avais
émis l'idée de jouer cavalier sinko au
après pas qui va peut-être fouache
quattro avec l'idée fou et rêve fou
gesing caudrot aulas petit taureau qui
peut tomber
reffouh h katia peut-être j'ai trois
quartiers pénible
donc il va pas le faire mais sinon ça
aurait put turbo d'euros 1
je pense qu'à faire caillasser 5
peut-être un jour essayer de faire qu'il
ya eu 6 qui a aidé qu'at-il à toutes les
cases noires
il a intérêt drôle autres et mayrand
rapide je pense baky plus fort en rapide
ça s'écrit tchouk là le surnomme le
grand nez un grand nez et gris cook sais
pas s'ils sont nés est supérieur au mien
ou pas y jouer
seydou d'acquista peu à une promenade
c'est pas on va voir j'ai bien envie
d'avoir un gros plan sur youtube mains
c'est du mauvais côté
je surpasse pas en taille donnée bas
j'espère on va essayer de regarder on va
essayer de regarder si on revoit de
profil on va voir
c'est quand on n'a pas les on n'a pas
les cadrages et pourquoi ils preuve le
cadre de dota leur île le cadre est de
face
voilà mais non mais on voyait mieux tout
à l'heure
ces livraisons kate mais bien sur ses
vraies enquêtes célébrer bayan ça ça se
promène sa se promènent
bon jeu
pas moi je pense sur lui bon je penche
plutôt sur telecinco
on est plus imposant aux caisses et
merci pour le compliment da qui se
baladent
gogol un joli nouvelle j'ai pas si vous
avez lu sur un chat twitch je m'attends
à ce que personne connaissent même le
titre ouverte après folle guys bah oui
ça peut être un bel objectif
meilleur joueur d'échecs de l'histoire
pour toi kiev après baky ou bas qui est
inclus
ouais je peux afin qu'ils soutiennent qu
gagnerait c'est sur un bas qui parlent
plus sûrement carlsen un an par baky non
mais c'est important de succion fait
c'est pas qu'ils instante mais du coup
sûrement carlson
donc parti qui continue à temps un bac i
can say think you pas aller là on va
avoir un coût
jean-michel cadrage sur l'échiquier il a
tout donné pour il a tout donné pour ce
plan auj tremble elle tremble regarder
au nom au nom le frérot au il a pas
réussi à tenir la can sans bouger
thierry villa eu la tremblote n'était
pas bien là n'était pas bien le plan
d'une vie way et bien qu'ils jouent fou
prend des 5 alors ça j'aime pas ça
j'aime pas parce qu'il vient jouer dans
le foot est roi
mais bon la ligne du coup c'est ed
cavale et b4 non mais ça va en fait de
base je voyais pas ce coup là mais ça va
en vrais fous du à pouvoir faire à trois
pour ce pour s'installer il va envoyer
les pièces là bas sur noir il a toutes
les cases moi en fait
c'est prend du coup je sais pas mais ça
enlève un peu de sang ça fout des trois
maintenant tu fais peut-être cavaliers
des 4 et surtout prend pions prends tu
vas avoir accès à eux trois du coup f4f
6 ça ça doit être cool
le cavalier arrivants ces cinq étaient
bien là en fait ça fait sens vous prend
des 5 c'est plutôt bien joué
ça valide un peu l'idée de fioul mais ba
qui doit dire que c'est vraiment une
merde de toute façon donc le cavalier
beckham va être pénible est pas fou bien
mais en fait je pense qu'aucun reppion
point québec adq koubéens là tu te
retrouve quand même à être un peu
recroquevillés le pion vian à 3 montus
affaires b3 et à tous elle va peut-être
jamais joué aux échecs
ça a l'air d'aller
ce que ben ali devraient échanger un
cavalier ben ali devra aller en vacances
à bali tu penses planche à voile tu
penses surf tup en soirée un en vrai
un truc des cavaliers ouais normalement
ils voyageaient pas sinon mais la f1
c'est encore une règle différente je
pense fait les échecs c'est pas un jeu
dogmatique un bavoir le cpp me détruis
ci avait que ça on n'a pas le seul
paix
hague mais là c'est un peu spécial parce
que les cavaliers ont des cases il ya
plusieurs casses pour les cavales donc
ça change un peu des choses
un truc que je n'arrive pas à suivre
réunir si je me trompe on m'a dit qu'il
y avait bien une hype de ouvrit la
fessée prend du coup on va dit qu'il y
avait une taille peu douves pour les
échecs en pologne
et là j'étais en train de regarder ils
ont 250 spectateurs en fait je n'arrive
pas à comprendre c'est tarifs des échecs
en pologne où tu suis pas tes joueurs en
la coupe du monde quand à deux joueurs
en huitièmes de finale
il a pris 2 c'est donc là ça s cavaliers
des cuatro mais ça veut dire je peux
expliquer en fait il a pris de ces po1
parce que là cavalier b4 ça fait moins
sens le foot va venir en bessin qui es
tu as l'impression que les blancs ils
facilement sur l'ale dame et du coup ça
sent moins dans le jeu quoi sur ces
prendra vraiment envie d'aller en d4
du coup tu veux cavaliers c5 et est
rentré dedans
il veut jouer du coup pour dire que le
foot est roi il servait à voir camaïeu
de peut-être pas cloud prend des
captures on prend des cadres dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui donnait les
quinze ans mais peut-être qu'il veut
cavaliers eu deux équidés qui a éprouvé
de dame prend 1,2 et d'essayer d'aller
envahir les dames
parce que ses pions ils pointent de faut
toujours regarder de quel côté sa pointe
commence à poindre c'est toujours
intéressant
et là on voit un sa pointe deux allèles
dames avec le jeu allèles dames c'est
forcément intéressant pour les blancs et
le pion à 4 ne se retrouver un petit peu
esseulé donc du coup est-ce que sur
cavalli des quatre cavaliers de on
prendra je sais pas cava lieux de ce que
tu peux jouer un dame b 6 pour couvrir
il ya un truc dans les pièces noires que
j'aime pas ici
en revanche vous prend des quatre qui
comprend le fait pas trop peur ce que ça
donne trop les cases noires et tous les
pions sont sur blanc avec le fou de
cases blanches
là on va pouvoir se balader sur noir de
partout
à cg on a rejoint michel cadrage sur un
échiquier vide et c'est hurel merci la
régie à temps il va tenter un zoom
attend ses zooms sur quoi ces zooms sur
une chaise
ces graisses ce zoom c'est quoi ce zoom
rôle là il a réussi à filmer le joueur
qui s'installe et différents zoom sur le
visage
exceptionnel aulas il a été bon là elle
était très très bon il a chopé great
choc en train de s'asseoir il a réussi à
le prendre à leurs cadres et là
franchement il a été bon aulas il est m
veepee de la journée ce cameraman aloalo
l'équipe caméraman numéro 4 excellent
boulot excellent boulot de ta part super
super plan au moment où grille tout ça c
est bien vrai mec là il a fait un
travelling exceptionnel
il a été très bon et si on regarde un
peu côté baky la position c'est
rassurant c'est rassurant
pour filmer plusieurs prestataires fois
tu as un peu fier des petits moules au
bahut à mon avis qui va être plus
heureux que celui qui gagnera la coupe
du monde 1 ces droits rebelles il a la
position
tous
c'est surtout sa griffe chaurette
mais il est pas bien duda en vrai
rami l'air pas mal en fait j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient des cinq tempo un an quel
dessein que c'est pas clair en fait
j'avais paca et des singles orange gris
tout pensif
mais pour les gens qui veulent le
résultat de la partie de la nouvelle et
qui demandent dix fois suivez mon
twitter les gars je vais le résultat sur
twitter quasi un stand dans mon nez est
supérieur à celui qu'eric lukens est
très clair je suis légèrement au-dessus
calme non critiques se bat bien mais je
suis un petit peu au-dessus cannes on
l'a bien vu là sur le zoom
c'est vite fait de cf
07 qu'elle regardait alors dit à fond
moi j'avais pas le cas et des signaux ça
va être compliqué et là
au brésil
en fait il faut savoir que twitter t'as
pas besoin de l'avoir en fait tu peux
suivre un infidèle à une timeline de
twitter sans sans l'avoir en fait c'est
juste un site internet
il faut envoyer une public hier par ce
fait du bien la pub là on souffle un
il vit tu fais un peu way se dandinant
peu quand même
je suis calé plein les enjeux de la
pollution ce que je faisais juste avant
higuain je suis prof coiba qui est mieux
non plus en fait
mais en gros il veut les cases pour ses
chevaux il veut peut-être venir avec du
cassis inco du dame b 6 il a les cases
noires en fait ils jouent sur cases
noires maxime je suis à boé je prends la
pub abbaoui frérot 1 les affaires sont
les affaires
en fait c'est plus un truc concret c
puis c'est ce que camaïeu de pour aller
bouffer des cas très fort et du coup
c'est les blancs qui pourrait être mieux
parce qu'il tape un peu plus vite du
côté où il pointe
havas lieu de dresser on attendait bon
la superbe gros plan sur sur des doigts
magnifique
manon hily thérapie dans les rapides
avec sa main armée fedoseyev aussi
regarder il faut un concours demain il a
posé les pions mais il ya montrez moi
aussi je peux le faire donc épreuve de
tam prend 2 c'est exactement la position
dont je parlais aziga l'instant
et donc là la question c'est ce que les
noirs peuple est ce que les blancs
peuvent et s'est rapidement de tirer
profit de leur jeu éventuel ce que la
colonne c'est wasquehal foucher cinq
tirs la baraque
ah ah
la lumière est vite il devrait quand
même se raser elle est pas belle sa
barbe
pourquoi pourquoi pas
oui on a un réel intérêt ce un peu des
normes généralement il ya une
décompression en fait puisque l'objectif
c'est d'arriver en finale
dams et 7 à il veut jouer sur son fou
engrangé sinko pas qu'on faut faire
gaffe avec les fous bathing faut faire
gaffe de ne pas perdre à 4 en fait
qui s'affolent s'effectue au sein la
jeune fille sa folle pour baky
y a que 15
la cohésion pour la gagne en fait
exactement c'est le seul joueur qualifié
qu'il la joue en fait
après c'est pas un bon tirage pour lui
de jouer ici plein qu'à carlson parce
que c'est le seul qui est heureux de le
jouer en fait s'en fout d'elle au corps
d'idées mais juste le l'éliminer jeu
juste le kent en fait le gars en fait tu
vas nous faire foule gros plan sur ses
doigts c'est que filmer des oies dans
fait jamais vu ça en fait non mais ça
fait dix minutes qu'on est sur les
ouates de heavy cha
ses intérêts stratégiques assène de
jouer cette coupe au c'est juste pour
gagner un titre qu'il a passé une
question d'ego 1
mons position il ya la paire de ouf pour
les blancs mais ça ne doit pas être
vraiment possible de la pressée
attendez mais ça marche comment les
tournois genre celui qui aime la coupe
du monde il est pas championnat non non
mais c'est une appellation fallacieuse
en fait c'est un coualy fire la coupe du
monde s'appelle coupe du monde on sait
pas pourquoi c'est pour faire croire que
c'est une coupe du monde mais en fait ça
ne l'est pas c'est terrible en fait ils
veulent se qualifier pour un tournoi qui
s'appelle les candidats qui lui-même
qualifie en fait c'est un satellite pour
un satellite qui lui-même qualifié pour
le match pour le titre de champion du
monde
parlez lui faut parfois fausse
appellation bas c'est le problème de
donner des mauvaises appellation
fait rage devrait baisser pour se
libérer le pion f en plein de cas de
figure c'est bien d'être parti c'est
coup je vais vous proposer
sur un cas il ya plus de viewer pour les
candidats à bâle c'est dur de faire plus
de 8 9 milliards 1 sur twitter en
français s'est compliqué hein je vois
que les russes et des gros pays des
chèques comme ça quand ils sont tous
réunis ils sont à 1500 2000 viewer c'est
dur en france est de faire plus de 8 9
10 milles 1 surtout en période estivale
avec les vacances la fin du confinement
et c'est enfin la fin la pause
on va être en 2001 on pourra les
candidats ouais bah c'était assez
exceptionnel un tu vois là on fait
autant qu'on en anglais alors qu'il
devrait avoir en ratio entre 20 et 30
fois plus de personnes d'ailleurs toutes
les autres langues
il ya aucune n'a aucune autre langue qui
est même à 1000 viewer en fait en vrai
je vais le tchèque
donc ça va être difficile de rappelle
que la france c'est pas un pays d chacun
de base c'est une anomalie qu'on soit
plus nombreux que les russes que les
espagnols que les polonais tu voi en 1
800 puisqu'on n'est pas sur ma chaîne
perso donc ça nous handicape et du coup
le premier autres instruments étranges
et c'est un gars en polonais justement
avec la méga qu'ils ont eue ils sont 460
tu vois donc c'est dur enfin on va pas
pouvoir maintenir cette heure et 1 c'est
pas possible en fait bon du coup
on à turin on adore bas il y tient
l'écran bon allez on va mettre un peu de
gens qu'on a à l'écran
une pause un peu bizarre voire bas ils
sont fous en b1 est un peu triste
c'est terrible aussi
elle allait elle doit être dur la
position le pion aux souhaits cela s'est
il ya quelque chose qui va pas pour les
blancs
il va passer un mauvais moment doit
rebeller
g 3g pas trop ce qui va lui préparer en
vrai de vrai
aussi tourner un pion dans son doigt
vas-y le font tous
mais je sais pas trop ce qu'il veut si
on fait juste tours fc 8 alors qu'on
décide d'un filtre et ça va faire h 4 x
6 ce doit être son idée il veut dire que
le four viens pas ici mais ce que ça
nous embête on est content quand même de
contrôler ses seins
faire ça comme ça
voir
il a fait cavaler c5 direct baky wayne
remarque pas débile un tours fc où je
voulais regarder mais à ce que le fou
appartient h6 non mais bon je pense pas
que j'en reparle vers des huit j'aurais
pas envie de me prendre une tour en c1
sans que contre la casse ça c'est trop
important en fait ce que ça fait gagner
une colonne bien faire fois ci ce qui a
aidé trois tours ces huit dames ces deux
là pour répondre à brigitte mon siège il
est vraiment très bien joué il ya une
méga confort mon siège les méga confort
après ouais c'est du beau sièges
c'est signe que c'est bien tu veux juste
infiltrés dieu tour ses huit qui avaient
des trois dames c2 et hk tu fais faut
acheter suite emballé pointu contrôler
la casse et un straupe important
aucun
il fait faux b5 ok il veut pas donner
qui a éprouvé trois dames ces deux pense
qu'il est la tour ans et 8 le fourrage 6
et après il faudra trouver une manière
d'infiltrer la colonne c'est ce sera
peut-être pas facile l'envoi visite à
l'écran un beau gosse aussi quand même
visite
bon
ça a l'air d'aller après tout peut
arriver dans cette partie c'est une
connerie je voulais fasciste par f5
peut-être pas
ça m'embête un peu de peur d'un thème
pour faire flasher 6
ça m'embête un peu je fais fois h6 ouais
ouais il veut qu il veut avoir le il va
avoir le plan avec elle cinq maintenant
intéressant ce plan ouais et du coup si
jamais il y aura toujours les fougères
saint cloud et 8 quand même qu'ils sont
pas si loin
c'est tendu un tendu comme parti
je veux pas vraiment les implants mieux
personnellement les jambes tard qu'ils
etc les blancs étaient mieux je trouve
pas moi je suis trois quarts puisque
j'ai envie d'être comme ça en fait
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de m'installer
comme ça faut savoir que je me mets je
me mets à la bien en fait généralement
flash pourrait aussi être comme ça mais
bon j'ai mon envie d'être assis comme ça
aujourd'hui j'ai envie d'être assis
comme ça si j'ai envie j'ai envie hein
mettez un tu as pas m'obliger à
m'asseoir comme tu veux frérot
trop les trois quarts des ventes un coup
d'oeil à ben en fait le truc c'est que
les cookies sont possibles on les voit
tous donc après quand tu joues tu
calcules et tu décides lequel est le
meilleur
en fait en gros les coûts qui peuvent à
jouer on les voit sans avec une petite
réflexion
ce qui est difficile à presser de
confirmer par le calcul de calais le
meilleur roger de ça la difficulté tient
pas en place
5 pour moi ça pourrait être un coup mais
je suis sûr que si je mets la turbine
est elle va pas aimer
si on prend tout reprend dams et 2
tu vois c'est ça qui est dur à voir
après c'est de tout bien calculé
jusqu'au bout voilà ça donne par exemple
à turbine et aime pas je suis vraiment
pas convaincu mais c'est vraiment assez
longue et assez tactique
j'essaye de mettre la variante un bon tu
as et une variante longue à calcul elle
fait neuf coups et là faut comprendre ça
se comprend que c'est les blancs qui
peuvent avoir une chance même si ça doit
être nul
vraiment partie sur le plan de la
colonne sais mais bon
le truc c'est qu'on a du mal à faire
tourner ses 8 et dams et 2
souvent ça tout dépend pour les
évaluations de position le calcul ça
dépend en fait des positions
moi je ne j'ai pas compris ça peut être
intéressant il peut y avoir des fous
prend ses cinq sens prendre deux dames
français cinq échecs quand la dame
harriman b6 il ya plus roy derrière donc
il est quand même mieux placé ce roi
karl scène ça a l'air d'être bien
d'euros
un petit tour en avoir c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant il vite jusqu'à un
pion de plus
martirossian qui
du nul pour se qualifier il joue solides
avec les blancs
et lâche en classe en classe et hyper
chaud
et si jan carlson ça se passe bien pour
les deux j'ai envie de dire
on a vu que visite avait une belle
position et on a vu que j'ai dit était
bien froid jean-michel cadrage de retour
ravet la régie franchement ils sont et
c'est des durs à cuire 1 la régie c'est
des durs à cuire
allez je renvoie une petite pub est on
en bouffe de la pub et ça fait plaisir
ça fait très plaisir
bon ça fait plaisir
être un bot qui fait les transitions est
allé plus basse qui partent 1 ça fait du
bien
jeudi la turbine à mon avis pas
grand-chose la pression de baky elle va
hein
pour ces huit volailles par pour ce plan
finalement vois pas pourquoi je vois pas
comment les blancs vont progresser le
seul mot qui m'inquiète c'est que j'ai
du mal à trouver un plan pour les noirs
aussi
et pas trop comment ils vont progresser
donc
pasqua sur trois ans on va échanger on
est content on va échanger notre mauvais
fou et du coup on aura vraiment toutes
les cases noires
kevin tu penses que doit friser le top
mondial non impossible
coke est passé devant la cam
qui qui s'est levée parce que c'était sa
table là bas je pense bas qui peut la
gagner aujourd'hui
on l'a vu marcher vrai
départage
récent demain mon avis aura maxime et
magnus au moins les joueurs qui peuvent
nous intéresser
les gars pour même pour maxime si
j'affiche à l'écran ce sera pareil les
gens ont calé sur twitter ses écrits par
touffes un feu qui se prennent par la
main arrêté dans le chat me dire kevin
tu peux faire si faire ça enfin les gens
demandent les gens demandent
petit à petit à prendre on a regardé sur
twitter
dans le cas
bon bah ils sont après les résultats
tout le monde si vous les résultats vous
vu d'un oeil
enfin c'est quand même très très simple
quoi là c'est vraiment très simple je
fais gaffe de mettre les résultats quand
il y en a sur twitter exprès pour pâques
les gens demandent ne va pas tout en
maître les résultats à l'écran même
quand on l'aimé il ya des gens qui
demandent
dans le cas
robert hockey la difficulté c'est trop
un plan pour baky
je sais qu'il ne veut pas répondre la
question est pourquoi tu ne joues plus
le tournoi classé fit du tout respectée
j'ai répondu plus de 500 fois la
question
donc je sais pas d'où tu es tu te dire
que je veux pas y répondre
donc
tours à b1
faire un coup peut-être comme damas cinq
du coût mais bizarrement je vois pas de
couilles outils ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre c'est hyper bizarre comme
position
notre dame à 5 tours ses sept tours c8
ouais ok damas un tour ses sept tours
ces huit jeux pas de plomb pour les
blancs en fait il a fait d'un mât 5 bat
qui étend ses sept tours c'est en fait
je vois pas de coût pour les blancs il
va faire four
d'un v6 ou f2
donc il va faire flouer là ça va être de
baqi al bakhit décider si vous devez
site web de damas cinq ou six veut jouer
je pense
je pense que c'est le truc est bon
évidemment je vais vraiment mettre le
résultat en fait la fin je vais être
obligé de mettre le résultat de mpl en
fait c'est ça devient insupportable
je vais être obligé de craquer pas ce
que c'est c'est pas possible en fait je
ne peux pas vous comprendre s'est passé
comme si moi j'aime bien le tennis est
en fait j'ai une appuyée avec les scores
s'appelle flash score même pas vraiment
la pub et quand je veux savoir ce qui
s'est passé la journée je vais sur flash
quand je regarde les résultats
je ne mets jamais arrivé de demander à
quelqu'un genre spécialement est ce que
tu sais ce qu'ils ont fait je
systématiquement je vais juste sur
l'appli et je regarde un peu les scores
des tournois d'ailleurs j'ai regardé ce
matin parce que je voulais savoir ce
qu'ils avaient fait medvedev
mais c'est ou de devoir polluer le
stream avec ce mvl kerry king qui est
pas très bien placé parce que vous savez
pas aller sur twitter regarder de
résultats quoi
le demander les scores sur un trimestre
comme sur une compet d'aujourd'hui non
mais non mais les gars non mais vraiment
soit vous êtes des trolls sauf d'être
stupide en fait il ya deux solutions
je pense que vous trop laid mais en fait
un stream c'est pas pour faire pour
répéter sans arrêt le score du match
plein vous l'avez on garde la partie on
attend vous avez fait ce point comme
events vous avez touché ce point comme
evans aussi vous avez les résultats il
ya tellement d'endroits où les trouver
enfin ça fait peur mais je pense c'est
du troll
dans mon cas
tordères ok je pensais qu'il ferait faut
un qui ferait là nul j'ai pas ce qu'il
veut faire avec les blancs tour c'est ça
arrive le tour c'est cette fois en
maintenant l'investissement f2 j'ai pas
la rave pour jouer en ligue 1 avec les
blancs en fait j'ai pas les j'ai pas le
temps pour les blancs sur les noirs
peut-être mais un
denquin
viens je préfère les blancs m excessif
et ours et 7 et que réussi à pénétrer en
c2 tu vas être bien parce que tu couvres
quand même les cases
après la turbine est donne ici b4 à bab
g b 4 et 1 était peut-être un peu nigel
avec la dame
ouais non ça doit être dangereux
honnêtement je la sens pas la position
je ne sais pas ce genre de positions que
je joue souvent et j'ai pas le feeling
h4 g4 g5 d'assurage 4g cas tu auras
fouet f4 instant teint pour se mettre
sur la case dès que tu vas faire j'ai
quatre en fait je mettrai mon four en f4
un bon plan pour l euphorie 6 le
problème déjà c'est que c'est loin c'est
qu'en plus ça va laisser les blancs
mettre une tour en c1 après c'est
possible
ensuite il ya six cas et c'est cette
annonce et cavale il est trop bon on va
pas l'enlever satie pense même pas en
fait c'est chelou j'ai l'impression que
pour gagner une game faut se mettre en
danger
ah ouais si tu réussis pas à planter
prépa faut se mettre en danger avec les
noirs en tout cas avec les blancs tu
peux essayer de presser un petit à petit
je comprends pas trop que la petite
turbine à de vieilles dames des huit
fatale aime pas quoi même pas tous et 7
b 4 à cela j'avais pas du tout le bk ça
c'était pas du tout dans mon règne
comprend pions prend
quatre et non ça c'est ça va être
dangereux et ça doit rester nul parce
que même si tu fais fou prend ses cinq
tours prend c'est simple que green bay 7
ça devrait tenir la finale ok ça
commence à être un peu too much
il a fait cavalier à 6 il veut vraiment
votre plan de mettre le cavalier ans et
je commence à pas et mais je commence à
pas et mais n'arrive peut-être cavale et
b4 plutôt est quelque chose qui me
déplaît dans la position de ba qui l'a
par plaisir mais sûrement il y avait une
bécane qui était gênant et du coup
peut-être tu dois faire ça
les mets japonais qu'il ya personne dans
le public n'y a jamais public dans les
toits des chèques à rangueil craque ça
intéresse personne en fait
ils empêchent b4 en vrai aussi après
s'il fait cai et b 4 à 3 et pourra faire
cavaler à seaska et c5 retour et ce sera
bien d'avoir provoqué à 3
mais bon est-ce qu'il a vraiment
cavaliers b4 danse orange après qu'est
ce que font les blancs c'est une autre
question ça c'est une autre question que
font les blancs
aux frais mais fou en dame b 6
attendez je viens d'avoir une idée pour
les blancs et cif est fou 17 tours c'est
cette fois je crois
l'idée c'est de contrôler la casse et 8
c'est la réponse du berger à la bergère
ça peut être une idée ça
c'est une sorte de de l'argent fait en
quelque sorte oui c'est pour pour
bloquer les contrôles des colonnes
francis beaucoup de problèmes aux blancs
mais justement tu opposé avec le fond h3
aussi essayé d'organiser à peut-être du
ta main d'am-dam j'ai un fou bay 6
sa plainte 3-2 j'aime avec du public
c'est gérable c'est surtout le public
qui veut pas venir qui dit la fin ce
n'est pas gérable tu peux mettre des
grands maîtres avec dix mille personnes
dans une salle ça c'est facile à faire
mais le truc c'est plus les gens qui
n'ont pas envie de venir
c'est plus ça le fond du problème
non non il ya un petit désagréable quand
même
sa femme qui revient joie d'ouvrir la
porte de chez moi
bang 1
quand tu remplis par un stade de france
- bercy facile ces endroits de cette
envergure tu penses à ce boom je pense
qu'il fait à paris bercy sur ampli r
après vente peut-être qu'on a fait une
grosse hype en france etc qui arrivent
mais de base sur en pierre
en cave
le grand danger sur paris a jamais eu
personne et c'est gratuit un état car en
scène et à tous les meilleurs
la personne qui vient
o'keeffe ou 17 qui pourrait être
intéressante pour les blancs
dans cas même en droit de chasser à
personne
non non il ya aucun tournoi il ya du
public 1 sur toute la saison
le saint louis à saint louis à personne
non plus a jamais personne
les joueurs qui les spectateurs après ça
fait chier les joueurs de prendre des
chèques de 100 mille balles à la fin des
tournois 1 c'est aussi une question hein
c'est pas pareil sans paroles 508 milles
sur le stream et qui est pas en pôle au
surpassement en fait sur réviser les
échecs en français c'est un petit peu
particulier en fait ce que j'expliquais
tout à l'heure c'est un peu le seul pays
en vrai on suit les compétitions au
niveau sur internet alors après
l'anglais il ya un peu de monde mais bon
en vrai en organique ya moins de monde
et ça représente une population peut
être dix fois ou 20 fois supérieure à la
nôtre qui peut regarder en anglais donc
la france fait cesser c'est un truc
vraiment très très spécifique à notre à
notre langue de regarder des échecs
mme avait organisé le top 16 à mulhouse
on a eu entre quinze et vingt visiteurs
par jour c'était gratuit ou payant les
entrées on va voir ce que fait purna en
vrai c'est genre de position que tout a
du mal à trouver des plans parce qu'en
fait les blancs ils veulent jouer
colonne c'est mais ils peuvent pas et le
fou qui contrôlent faire flouer 3 tu
veux pas tu te fais échanger attaques
allaient droit c'est pas ton côté encore
essayer de retrouver des plans les
russes regardent pas un an je crois
qu'on cumule et ils ont mille ou 1500
spectateurs pour une population
russophone qui s'intéresse aux échecs
qui doit être minimum de fautes deux
fois supérieur mais je pense plutôt
trois fois sans compter que c'est leur
variable beaucoup de gens qui jouent aux
échecs en russie face et il devrait être
minimum dix fois plus que nous mais je
pense plutôt 20 ou 30
non en fait les gens regardent passer un
peu une anomalie en fait le français
il ya peu de regards du bagne où 1 pour
un 4 ème et fou un john adams et celle
qui peut être intéressant pour à 4 c 5
et on va récupérer à 2 de toute façon je
voulais faire dams et 7 pour aller sur
ces 2 mais surtout pour la carte assure
qui a réalisé cinq est rentable partout
en fait ça va pas gagner ça pour les
blancs mais encore qu'il peut tenter
peut-être ça fait quand même un pion
plus il ya du tourin qui rentrent mais
bon il ya le fou qui va venir en outre
oif atteint foot il y en avait 4 ouais
je sais pas
ouais peut-être fou un pur et dur d'un
v6 juste vous prend 1,4 ces cinq là y'a
peut-être b3 qui prend 1,4 si on prend
étape ici ok peut-être fou hein
son cavalier à 6g pas trop senti le coup
et peut-être ça ça peut être une option
est fou b3 du coup
ce que peut-être une dame s'est cette
fois quatre et c5 trouver 5 comprend
tout un
pour essayer de sortir du problème de la
colonne c'est énoncer clairement
avantage blanc melaye acquis et b3 qui
est des cats mais c'est un peu du bol je
pense que baky have va vraiment être
plus fort en rapide mais il faudrait
qu'ils réussissent à prendre là nul ici
le plan pour baky je pense jouer la
colonne s'est globalement
ouais on rapide je pense qu'il va le
faire craquer en vrai là c'est quand
même les blancs à deux pisteurs tous les
plans qu'on trouve ça avec les blancs
avec les noirs on trouve pas de jeu
bon
on y réfléchit
croit tellement pas au jeu de pure où je
pense tellement qu'il va rien faire je
n'arrive pas à l'imaginer tentes et de
bâches bas qui en fait ici je sais pas
pourquoi mais j'imagine pas rentrer dans
un fou prend à 14 ans fait fou un fou
prend 1,4 ça a l'air assez logique
le fait d'avoir aidé
un jour de repos ça joue beaucoup plus
sur la fatigue anxieuse de l'âge on est
tous égaux face à une journée intense en
face en plus non non c'est fatigant
parce qu'en fait une journée dans un
joueur d'échecs ça dure longtemps il ya
3 4 3 4 5 heures de prépa avant la
partie après il faut jouer la partie est
du coup les tournois à son nom et c'est
éprouvant donc il vaut mieux pouvoir
éviter les départage
baky ferreux et la moindre erreur de
piau rhône et c'est selon iba je trouve
que puis rooney fait une bonne partie
globalement vrai cavalier ah si j'ai
vraiment pas trop aimé mais après je
comprends pourquoi pas qu'il a fait il
avait peut-être pas trop le choix
on a prévalu en place plutôt révision
des lignes déjà apprises aux biens
découvert de nouvelles lignes en
fonction de ce qu'ils aient joué les 2 1
à les seconds ans après c'est tout un
tout un travail un plat toute une équipe
qui t'a doté passât parce que je suis
déjà intéressé rendez ce compresseur
solutio nist de loin je vois regard des
belles études de temps en temps mais
c'est un vice que je n'ai pas
bon ça va faire un nul ici viennent
qu'au carlos n avoir pu rhône contrebas
qui fut un cavalier b4 peut-être mais
par principe j'aime tellement pas ça ça
m'effraie
il vient de jouer du rhône il a fait
preuve est celle où qui faisait peur en
fait plus on analyse et puis ça faisait
peur ce truc
j'avale et b4 je sais pas ça m'effraie
le cavaly tu peux pas plus le protéger
il est bloqué comme ça un coup droit de
côté et il ya 3 qui arrive je sais pas
ça je n'aime tellement pas
donc du coup pour moi il faut cacher la
dame sait pas où jamais très indécis ce
fou prend à 4 qui avait laissé cinq à
mleiha b35 problème qui avale et prend à
4d prend 1,4 et là ça va être dur parce
que le x 6 devient moins important parce
que maintenant il ya deux colonnes
ouverte et le fou va pouvoir taper sur
des six les gars je commence à être
inquiet
là je commence à être vraiment inquiet
ça donne l'impression de poussettes que
rooney 6
il a fait dans
c'est tempo et donc qu'il l'avait
heureusement ok ça va tout jouer sur
cette position x 4 qui haïssez 5-fu b3
cavaliers prendrions prend dame ces deux
dames français de tours français deux
airois quelque part peut-être h3 est-ce
que ça ça peut se tenir facile pour baky
ou pas c'est vraiment là qu'est la
position critique parce qu'il ya quand
même qu'ils ont de moi même si c'est des
pions doublé mais surtout structure
supérieure pour les blancs parce que bon
fou contre mauvais fou c'est les blancs
qui peuvent taper et noir s'ils vont
devoir défendre
on va voir je pense que c'est la ligne
george la perfection je pense que ça
doit faire un nul ouais mais ça peut
être poussette ans et s'arrête là ce
serait la deuxième quand il reste à voir
loin dans les positions aux échecs dont
il faut s'entraîner au calcul un tout
bêtement faire des exercices d exercice
des exercices des exercices en laye a
pas le choix
il n'y a pas de choix mais là il ya
petite souffrance quand même petite
souffrance pour baky les exercices
tactiques sur chasse comme au début et
puis après une fois que tu es vraiment
forcée des livres d'entraînement en
calculant c'est aussi simple que ça
parce que quand on voit il peut y avoir
aussi une intuition sur nombreux coups à
l'avant sans vraiment avoir calculé
ouais mais tu es obligé de vérifier par
le calcul aux échecs ça peut coûter trop
cher une faute celle des screen de
problème pour repasser sur les rôles par
les problèmes simples ou autre enfin je
veux moi je fais 2 3 je fais 2 3h de
d'exercice par jour pendant cinq six ans
peut-être quatre cinq ans je sais plus
j'en ai fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
à un moment donné battu des exercices
faciles ils viennent de plus en plus
dures et tu le sens de toute façon quand
tu réussis à trouver vraiment deux trois
coups tu trouves en cinq six sept coups
un petit à petit tu passes au livre plus
que dès que les entraîneurs tactique sur
sur internet
ça ça va être sous françois pour les
gens disent non mais quel système cloud
b3 ça va forcément être souffrance un
peut-être pas prendre en b3 faut
peut-être faire f 5 autres choses j'en
sais rien jouer pour f 5 mai passé un
pion - même si c'est des pions doublé b
et que et que et que et que c'est dur
d'en faire un pion passé c'est quand
même un pion de plus un
mais bon si vous y vous si vous y tenez
et pendant trois ans vous faites deux
trois heures d'entraîneur tactique par
jour et quand je dis faire les
entraîneurs tactique c'est pas en
répondant au téléphone en regardant un
fil facebook ne sais pas quoi vous et
laissez le téléphone allumé mais c'est
vraiment le faire et c'est le faire
sérieusement calculant les variantes
jusqu'au bout et en et en le faisant
lien souhaite ça si vous êtes à cicc
fait ça pendant deux trois quatre ans
vous allez forcément bien joué 1
pourquoi passer aux livres à bref c'est
quand mon nez quand t'es trop fort c'est
plus assez dur sur internet
fais-tu rhône après d'après l'ordif ou
des cinq tours points à 2 est
intéressant pour lui mais ça j'y crois
pas trop
- qui est un coup vraiment qu'ils
fassent mal mais ça j'y crois pas pour
moi c'est vraiment fou b3 mais je suis
pas sûr que ba qui prennent en b3
on a des durs quand même en ligne dix
voitures et affronté fanta 0 exercices
tactiques en ligne qui termine par un
avantage stratégique à la fin je sais
vraiment que de la tactique pur et dur
après quand atteint un certain niveau
fait tu fais des livres pour les joueurs
entre 2002-2003 et quand même quelque
chose que je sais qu'il a vu fait les
mêmes livres que moi on en reparle avec
lui bah hockey et les exercices ont
beaucoup plusieurs parce que des fois
l'avantagé à la fin c'est que tu as un
bon fou contre un mauvais fous que tu as
une case ou enfin voila tu sais pas
vraiment au début de l'exercice je sais
pas ce que tu vas gagner tu as gagné une
pièce un pion une case que tu étais
moins bien au début qu'il fallait le
comprendre et que tu a égalisé enfin tu
sais pas quoi donc c'est différent après
un mois puis rennes qui se retrouve mal
autant c'est pour ça que je disais que
je pense qu'en rapide bas qui va être
plus fort uni mahler de stresser
en tout cas quand lyon entre 1600 et
2000 et l'eau tu peux aller enfin à
soumont la via des recommandations livre
tu peux en trouver chez ba qui aussi il
fait foulée 5 qui a dû considérer que le
four b3 petit quelque chose que j'ai pas
vu c'était moins dangereux mais du coup
leur dis aime bien phu b5 ça qui
m'inquiète parce qu il te reprend à deux
dames c4 avoir gardé il ya là il ya un
truc que j'ai raté sans ordi kelly l'ont
tour à 8 je reviens et ça c est il veut
jouer cette idée s'est décalé de la
colonne s'est décalé la colonne et
rendre le fou inutile parce que la casse
c'est un est plus un problème en fait on
rentre avec la colonna et on va pouvoir
jouer fou bécade vs x 6 c'est plus
stratégique en fait
ça je pense que c'est plus dangereux en
soi
non mais les gars mais sa fin les livres
que moi j'ai lu pour montrer nos calculs
ça vous sert à rien enfin tant que vous
n'êtes pas au moins 2100 au 2200 ça sert
à rien pour le moment entraînez-vous sur
une chaise comme vous avez tous les
outils dont vous avez besoin puis après
quand vous serez fort on verra pas fort
vous aurez le niveau pour faire ces
choses-là on verra mais là pour le
moment il faut se booster en tactique il
faut faire tout les toutes les leçons de
chaises comme un peu facile il ya quand
même beaucoup de matériel un ce soit en
français après en anglais en a il y en a
beaucoup
avant d'arriver là faut travailler un
des quatre c'est bien ouais mais tu fais
comment avantage en est pour le temps
investi pas terrible je pense vous êtes
matrix et par le temps faites aux échecs
c'est beaucoup plus facile de jouer
quand on est bien donc on a besoin de
moins de temps
t'inquiète pas que si tu en fais deux
trois heures par jour tu retombera sur
les mêmes
c'est sûr je suis en train de faire un
livre de la garde et c'est vraiment
instructif mais ça sert à rien d ouvrir
avant 2000 fixé sur ben ça c'est évident
avant 2008 même pas la peine de ces même
pas la peine d'y toucher même avec un
bâton 1
une demi centre conseil qu'un livre ça
après faut demander à bas qui y voit des
gens qui connaissent mieux fait
longtemps que je joue plus de tous les
livres de quality chess globalement la
plein qui sont bien vous ces quatre
c'est bizarre ça se met dans notre
vis-à-vis
alors après a peut-être une idée sur
tours à huit bonne façon et avait fait
retour à 8
et du coup il veut te voir maintenant si
on prend un tour en a pas qui est
provocatrice chez skil et une mare
loterie ok il a foutu on prend
d'apprendre dame prend tour prend tour à
huit matches ok c'est son idée je pense
c'est fou ces quatre tours à vis de toi
pour prendre un tour points et on a
cavalier caps camatte du couloir à la
fin donc c'est pas idiot on comprend
l'idée je pense qu'il a voulu éviter
dame c4 quoi qu'il y aura huit parce que
le pion est cloué et du coup y'a pas b4
il a dû vous lui vouloir éviter ça
donc franges et 6 à la forêt
k
ça c'est toujours aussi nul doute à la
partie un peu beauf et grichka plus de
trois minutes
ça pourrait être complexe pour sacha
visite
c'est marrant trop rares bali give up
elle dame pour essayer d'aller créer
quelque chose sur le roi plutôt malin
vif et d'os et c'est bizarre comme
position dure à évaluer parce que
normalement ça devrait très bien pour
les blancs mais c'est pas si claire
martirossian en train d'aller se
chercher ça nul
pas sûr qu'il la trouve mais je pense ça
doit être une forteresse calme après à
vérifier et vident leurs chants clan d'
elvis a su retour des 8 au c'ur tour des
huit il a tour à chaud suite damas je
suis au c'est joli ça tour des huit la
tourache huit ans ça c'est hyper beau
sur recettes et adam prend des huit
suroît g7 et du coût d'un point dé 8
aussi et sur damas chouity adam d83 g7
fou des quatre oies monsieur shankland
et ça va se qualifier pour la champions
là et ben voilà notre premier enfant
premier joueur n'était pas vraiment pour
lui de base mais la championnat qui va
qui va la gagner et jolie le tournage
suit 1 pour gagner après c'est dommage
mais ça marche aussi dans l'autre sens
ça marche aussi dans l'autre sens et
lâche ancla qui s'imposent
il peut être content sam
il sera en quarts de finale pas de
talent mais beaucoup de travail et ça
lui permet d'aller plus loin dans le
tournoi et de s'octroyer un jour de
repos demain assez bien joué un jeu
raconte maxime peut être au prochain
tour en tout cas la chambre qu'à avance
sans faire de bruit
va bosser demain
mais c'est un bon résultat pour lui il
se qualifie déjà pour les grands prix
fille des îles en quarts de finale après
six heures c'est pré-retraite art ce
leader s'était déjà retraité way méchant
cloud c'est peut-être pré-retraite aussi
vrai mais travaille beaucoup
alors piotr il dit a dû avoir un ouais
il ya dû avoir un coup parce que il a
fait tourner donc c'est la variante
qu'on a regardé en fait
donc il a déjà écrit deux livres ce que
je crois que son bouquin il a écrit une
suite
il est déjà de bouquins quand même c'est
pas rien
c'est pas rien de livres c'est demain
aujourd'hui à demain on va pas non plus
mais trop de choses la même journée
pourtant que la régie montrer à gillard
depuis vingt-cinq minutes tout est bon
enfant
ce qu'ils préfèrent adore la paire de
foule attentat ou cavaliers généralement
la paire de fou mais après il ya des
exceptions pour diriger 6 bat g si c'est
simple genre ton tour pranger 6 c'est
pour menacer cavale et le 4.4 dams et 4
dames ses quatre tours c4 et surtout
rail 8,3 g7 houphouet fuite et six pieds
au carlton ça fait nul hein on les voit
là en direct
on voyait depuis un moment qui avait pas
grand chose à faire
voir ce que ça donne baki
cachant clan bravo à lui je voyais pas
du tout en quarts shankland même payé il
se qualifier et ouais ils sauteront un
jour de repos en emportant demain avant
la dernière ligne droite c'est important
je se reposait après je pense que il
souffrira au prochain tour contre maxime
icart yakine messi gagne après en deux
ans et demi sera favori est peut-être
même suivant qui se qualifie donc à
coiffer y aura peut-être un build it
mais bon en tout cas ils s'offrent une
possibilité d'aller jouer les candidats
en attendant shankland maxime quelques
jours de repos aujourd'hui alors oui et
non parce qu'il doit quand même se
préparer pour demain
bon faut pas penser que les joueurs là
ont beaucoup de temps libre
comment déjà forcément à regarder les
prêts les prêts pas pour demain fort
heureusement avoir un maximum d'énergie
pour les départage
fort que d'un camus rabat actuellement
c'est le dernier jour amérique en
compétition donc il pourrait être le
seul américain au candidat l'année
prochaine donc il serait numéro un
américain très clairement
quoi qu'il en soit quoi qu'on en dise si
c'est le seul américain aux candidates à
boîte numéro cinq sur la sur le papier
tu es le seul à pouvoir être champion du
monde a en bout d'un moment moi c'est ça
que j'aime pas trop dans le dans le
classement fit c'est c'est qu'à un
moment donné suivant finale de coupe du
monde pourquoi tu dois avoir moins de
classement que un gars qui fait pas de
coup d'éclat quoi disons que tu peux un
peu vite sur tes acquis aux échecs
l'as tu veux être le meilleur il faut un
moment donné pouvoir aller gagner un
tournoi c'est important
tu vas pas faire une hausse qualifiée
pour les prochaines semaines' ça fait
longtemps qu'ils jouent pas bien fabiano
un papa bien par rapport à haut niveau
qu'il a eue
en déclin alors après peut-être qu il se
reprendra
j'aurais ribes les coûts sur les papiers
sont obligatoires
toi ben ali vie dit ça à l'air d'être
chaussures que visiter bien mais de
rabat il y trouve son compte le jeu
alors m l'échiquier côté noir est on
voit que c'est pour ça que l'ordi juger
si c'est pas une partie facile pour
etienne un nouveau gros plan sur les wad
jour pas de calme sur baky non on en
aura peut-être une demain parce que je
sens que l'on n'y pourrons pas le
remettre
et si vidic gagnera deux joueurs en
moins donc on aura une chance d'avoir
bâti en cas mais je pense qu'ils ne
mettront pas personnellement
sont les femmes n'y a plus de fans dans
le tournoi mixte il ya un tour à féminin
il ya encore bien forcément des femmes
puisque c'est un torrent il ya que des
femmes mais dans le tournoi mixa ya plus
de jouer actuellement
c'est vrai qu'on voit pas bac il monta
beaucoup baky de 400 lots n'est pas
ainsi qu'il ya bien un moment où tu
perdes si tu n'as pas vu depuis
longtemps tu perds tes points l'audi
plus qu'aux menons nom super g était
point l'eau c'est ça c'est mal foutu
mais c'est comme ça là clairement sur la
forme du moment bas qu'il est pas du
tout 60e mondiale par exemple il serait
plutôt top 30 voire même table 25 voire
mieux
d'enghien
c'est à pavie s'il s'arrêtait maintenant
je crois qu'après cinq ans tu deviens
inactif mais oui pourrait théoriquement
jouer une partie contre un gars avec
1000 et l'ofii de le battre et du coup
se réactiver et numéro un mondial
pendant pendant 10 15 20 ans mais tant
qu'il ya pas quelqu'un qui a un meilleur
look lui pourrait le faire mais y'a pas
d'érosion de thé point bas car ça me
garde son élan jusqu'à jusqu'à son décès
vrai
or geste gère le papier sur les coups
lorsqu'il reste plus que plus dangereux
et pas comme tu as 30 secondes de
rajouta toujours au minimum 30 secondes
en 30 secondes tu es quand même capable
d'écrire de lettres et un chiffre est ce
qu'on peut faire notre l odc je crois
ouais c'est pour ça que kasparov était
toujours de 1800 exactement s'il veut
silver cross
sans le train fait rien les verts
seraient dans le mixte à wissant les
meilleurs sans le tour a féminin les
meilleurs seraient dans le mixte ça
c'est vrai on a au moins une ou deux ce
serait pas mal
donc 1
je pense qu'ils en auraient invité il
aurait donné des wild card après pour se
qualifier ça aurait été dur pour se
qualifier honnêtement ça aurait été dur
tout cas pour celles dans la zone europe
ça aurait été compliqué quand même
j'étais en privé affecte le oui tout
autant qu'il n'y a pas de nos échecs que
tu joues une partie même carlson qui
avait joué une partie en ligue
norvégienne contre un joueur à 2003 dans
un truc sans aucune importance
la partie pour lui occupe elle a
exactement la même importance qu une
finale de championnat du monde dans le
calcul de l eau il n'y a pas de
gradation via l'importance du tournoi
je compte maintenant un club et je vais
avoir le choix entre montpellier
toulouse de quelques conseils si tu
habites à montpellier montpellier cet
habitat toulouse toulousain frérot là
j'ai envie de te dire là qu'est la
question est vite répondu hein
et c'était un titre de championne du
monde oui
ce que c'est obligatoire la chemise
ouais je crois que c'est dans le dress
code fois au psg mais c'est ça
ce que la barre des 1900 et dans les
endroits pour call c'est non impossible
dans un moment j'y croyais vraiment là
ça paraît un peu plus dur mais
envisageable encore et bien sûr il est
tellement incroyable ce joueur il a joué
j'ai ici serait il a bien compris le
problème qu'on avait montré un peu plus
tôt
avec un pool balancier regard ouais mais
alors il ya un dress code ya un joueur
il ya deux ans ou trois ans s'était fait
éliminer parce qu'il était venu en
bermuda c'est un peu complexe qu'il
était venu le premier jour en bermudas
personne n'y a rien dit et le deuxième
jour il ya un arbitre qui lui à qui la
mit forfait du coup suivant enfin tu
prends pas de risques parce que tu peux
te prendre forfait d'un arbitre de
manière complètement arbitraire
justement donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
viennent en vienne en chemise histoire
de pas prendre le risque de se prendre
un forfait sans raison quoi alors que tu
as d'état frontale et je rejoins du top
niveau comme comme amoureux n'y a ni
peut venir avec des t-shirts avec des
chats dessus des trucs complètement
degen il ya personne qui dit rien mais
quand t'es pas top top niveau
si tu suis pas le dresscode tu peux tu
peux et le joueur voulait aller changer
de mec l'ami forfait direct il a dit je
vais à l'hôtel je me change revient dans
15 minutes il lui a dit non en termine à
doter venu en bermuda termine à dos je
caricature un peu mais c'était quasi ça
ils se sont un peu insulté avec l'
arbitre après en fait pas disons que
l'arbitré a insulté c'est plus à
l'habitude a dit tablier comme un gitan
va de changer et du coup c'est parti en
n'importe quoi ces partis ont tu me fais
des insultes racistes et/ou du coup il
lui a mis un il ya mis un bal en grosso
modo faudrait relire l'histoire c'est un
peu vieux al arabi toile arbitres à
l'arbitrage insultes racistes delà de la
part de l'arbitré s'est passé c'est le
joueur qui a pris pénalité et le gars
actuellement je crois qu'il doit être
président d'un truc
pas la fidh mais je me rappelle plus de
quoi peut-être aller q où je plus quoi
voit il a en poche peu importe ça ça
passe a pas eu grande influence
mais c'est les échecs c'est tout ça
c'est que ça en fait c'est que ça tout
le temps en fait mais oui c'est retombé
sur le joueur donc bon tu veux pas
prendre le risque et tu préfère mettre
des chemises histoire de pas te prendre
un conflit débile comme ça quoi
mais bon suivant que ouais mais bon
double file a des bonnes relations avec
la fidh et où il un peu dans les petits
papiers donc il va il aura pas deux il
n'y aura pas de soucis double of on
avait bien vu dans les commentaires ça
ça avait fait bondir les les gens dans
les commentaires qu'ils avaient fait
pour pour les candidats face c'était
incroyable en fait mais bon il s'est pas
fait virer il a encore invité il sera
encore là en fait c'est vrai c'est à des
bonnes relations avec des gens en fête
aura jamais de problème si t'as pas les
bonnes relations
tu peux te faire tu peux te faire boulos
pour pas grand chose donc
les échecs c'est fou ça mais bon ça peut
être que les échecs
attends je chanterai dire un truc
il ya eu d'autres scandales avec ce gars
bon peu importe peu importe
fondamentalement je suis pas contre le
dress code c'est bien d'avoir des
limites dans ce que tu peux mettre un
mais après il faut que ce soit clair
faut pas que ce soit un jour pas droit
le lendemain tu n'as pas le droit à quoi
il faut que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tout le monde si ces chemises ses
chemises pour tout le monde
faut pas qu'ils aient de passe droit on
s'est trompé d'iraniens vous dire que
l'autre iranien en train de gagner ça
sent la drôme s'est trompé d'arméniens
joue bien avec un quand même
on
c'est sur baky je fus est revenue en
bessin qu'après j'ai six voiliers pas
pris l afld et on prend un victor francs
8 il a besoin et non il a fait g6 tu
coûtes empruntant points 8 et fourbe et
avec
si je si les échecs se rapproche du
poker non c'est juste que dire il à ce
coup danse à rennes joue quoi ça aide à
ces dames à faire une métaphore face
pour faire une métaphore pour que les
gens comprennent en fait c'est surtout
ça
pas quand on va à qui va la jouer mais
ok c'est pas peut-être qu'ils aient b3
pour caler des quatre noms on peut faire
ça genre surtout ces trois genres quand
même qu'il y ait des quatre à la rigueur
filet de pions et s'activer am alive
elles paraissent que ça peut passer un
truc comme ça ou pas patient parce qu'il
y avait 4 5
k&b trois fous ces trois pour empêcher
qu'ils avaient décalé on a notre bac qui
à l'image
enfin un peu de baky et peut-être dams
et 5 pour [ __ ] le cavalier en d4 genre
un truc comme ça on va le tenir je pense
qu'elle envoie une variante que j'ai
calculé à la manse ouais j'y crois et
l'envoyer cavalli b3 bas qui il envoie
le cas et b3 qui allie la danse orange
il a assez dans le daniel ouais c'est ça
ces dames c5 et d4 et la finale de foot
couleurs opposées regardez-moi ça en bas
qui se demande pourquoi tu joues
or il est débouté pu route survenu les
dégoûter le fourbe et sinko qui va il le
regrette
et oui il s'est fait pas kid pas bien ou
alors que north nikkei qui est en train
d'envoyer un chèque de 5 millions
d'euros à ba ki hun pour ce gros plan
terrible bas qui fait mal aux issues
isuppli rhône isuppli rhône assez
terrible
alala nul elle elle va être assurée les
gars
c'est pas possible pour que rooney
drogba qui l'accusent des petits un
point d'exclamation terrible point
d'exclamation cpp point d'exclamation
alpha échec au l'échiquier n'est pas
assez qualitatif pour baky avions une
idée daglan oloron le pauvre
il n'est pas bien il est pas bien rompue
rhône aux issues dams et quattro ça va
changer un très vilain j'annonce
j'annonce les changes des dames et le
cavalier en des cuatro terminé pour pure
rhône
il ne gagnera pas aujourd'hui il va
s'incliner demain terrible il est que
rien
et oui tu n'as plus à damas
time c'est pas possible j'avais dix
arrivant des quatre
on le voit bien la caméra le régime s'y
est pas trompé c'est pas qu'ils
l'actualité de ce tournoi bilan des 4 1
le cavalier il veut en d4 les amis est
tellement dégoûté du rhône il sait qu'il
était un peu mieux face au président et
c'est un coup de crocs 1
voilà y'a plus rien pour les blancs y
arrivant des quatiers transports le
cavalier est trop fort c'est terminé à
dos aux noms changent la came c'est
terrible c'est quand même terrible de
changer la cam à ce moment là c'est du
jamais vu
la fff devrait arriver à voir tour ses 8
ans instante
ça va partir instant
le tour s'est vite va partir instante
alors toute recherche de fichiers bas
qui voient ils peuvent pas avoir trop de
baky à l'antenne en fait
j'ai parfois ils mettent duda qui est en
train de enfin deux ait note
ah non en fait il met tout ça parce que
gris truc c'est magnifique il a trois
minutes il s'est barré
sahin fougue riccio qu'en fait ils
gagnent en fout en fait
terrible
les menaces matin en fait il a tout
calculé vachement un truc c'est que d'un
match 6 si tu fais roi h7 ya tour points
à 6 puis on prend 1,6 dame prend 1,6 et
perpète
[Musique]
du coup tu fais roi 3,7 en fait t'as pas
le choix
[Musique]
attends mais c'est hyper compliqué en
vase ok c'est pas si simple ça s'est
moins bien mais a peut-être d'autres
coûts
tours fc est aussi cavalier e set tu
peux pas partir la ja tampon h6 trois
fuites qui a rédigé six échecs seul coup
à seissan fait et c'est ça la drau
réfugiant dans le premier set bien sûr
je lui dis si les barres et cissé barrès
et qui sait qu'il ya une droguée qui a
valu aux 7
complexe 3,8 il ya des découvertes des
trois justice et quoi qu'est-ce qui la
turbine qui a été 5 3 et 5 dames hk 3g 6
dames eu quatre drôles et c'est un truc
de ouf leurs variantes qui a fait tour à
4 il a fait d'un nul 6 échecs ok ça va
faire drôle à partis de dun c'est la
drogue y ait ces dames 6 tours fc être
car il y avait du reste et ses droits
ah je vois bien fou prend des 4 j'en
prends des 4
b 3 aura droit je crois ce que ça c'est
juste complètement nul ou pas ça tu dois
pas faire b3 pourquoi ça va bien drôle
quand même hein c'est peut-être petite
poucette quand même pour les noirs
la doute agri succéderont rang des
quatre joué par tune
assez génial les joueurs qui se demande
si les trois fois même position ya eu 47
pour trois fois la même position
les arbitres se sont implantés cette
fois ci
bon il se barre le premier à vide qui
avait fait inouï ce à quoi il vit chest
c'est mieux pour les blancs ça va être
soufre est pourquoi pour fait d'os
martirossian ça doit être nul hein ça
doit être parce que sur des cas tu
comprendras epyon sav forteresse donc
martirossian il avait gagné du je crois
et ferrand martirossian shankland est en
fête et vie dit habib il est
complètement gagnant voitures avis dit
champion de martirossian qualifié
sûrement
ça fait deux caméras pour 3 et chic et
ouais ça laisse deviner celui qu'on aura
pas vrai on a vu en aura pas baki je
pense qu'on fera si ça fait deux nuls
comme ça je pense qu'on fera pas de
résumé des des parties ce soir
parce que c'est pas on a fait déjà il ya
la drau fut c'est pour refaire une vidéo
aujourd'hui on dira prêt pas prêt pas
prêt pas je pense qu'on fera quelque
chose après les départage prépare
un voyage en france et quatre pouces et
3 au 6 mai femme vous faire un petit
résumé ce soir
féminin cornetto sinon on est haut ils
regardent plus la fin il est parti en
tournoi face à volovitch enfin on a le
droit de prendre un peu de temps pour
nous aussi
si on peut éviter de bosser au lieu de
10 heures par jour faire huit heures et
demie surtout que là en fait on a
d'autres vidéos c'est terrible un truc à
faire on va quand même essayer de
prendre une heure une heure et demie
tranquille quoi à part refaire un énième
un point sur un tableau féminin là
c'était juste mathieu qui voulait parler
des des françaises fassent sinon ils
regardent pas non plus hein je te
rassure
fous ces trois c'est l'autre option
les entraînements qu'il a regardé
forcément non tu sais quelle joueuse il
entraîne hâtivement rue tu as des infos
tu sais qu'à jouer dix secondes
du coup il a son tournant en ce moment
si la pelouse d'un tournoi ça
m'étonnerait que qu'ils fassent des
résumés des parties 1
4 quant aux noms pourquoi ils seront en
crète
bon là il a pris la colonne a le truc
c'est qu'il a la colonne la colonne ça
avec le fou va faire wife i3 cette tête
f5 pourquoi on peut mettre laurent 17
ans et là y'a rien à faire dans la
position non mais là quand on était en
plus il à son tournoi
l'étang à mitry et d'autres non alors ya
enfin il ya soit des tournois mixtes
soit des tournois féminins les tournois
les tournois réservés aux hommes
n'existent pas il ya aucun tournoi qui
n'est réservé qu'aux mia soit là les
tournois mixtes tous les tournois du
monde où les tournois féminins en fait
il n'ya que deux catégories
donc 3 f2 jouer ouais ça c'est sûr que
c'est nul
du coup nous apprend prendre parti de
regarder les tournois qui sont ouverts à
tous des gt par mix non mais une femme
qui était 7e mixte
casting qui est joué
une partie est nul voilà ça se sent en
fait il ya plus trop de jeux jeux trop
de plans en fait je pense qu'à faire
tourner son adversaire m la tour de
ramener son roi en fait c'est peut-être
même baky qui pousse un peu mef va pas
vraiment comment en vrai
ont ils appris et prendre quand même
puisque serait pas poussette pour ba qui
ont des seins quand même un peu faible
je ferai pas pour reprendre la compet a
pas du tout héraklion a expliqué mille
fois en stream
ça n'intéresse pas j'en ai pas envie
j'ai passé déjà énormément de temps sur
ma chaîne twitch à partager ma passion
des échecs je peux pas en faire plus en
fait pour les échecs j'en ai déjà fait
assez et je vais pas sacrifier les
quinze jours que j'ai de libre dans
l'année pour encore aller jouer aux
échecs
un livre est vrai aussi surtout ses amis
qu'il a écrit mais oui
c'est en effet bien les autres tournois
doit être masculin sinon on fait que
dumiste je peux tout à fait d'accord
avec toi gildas je peux tout à fait
d'accord avec toi c'est bien qu'il est
on un féminin pour pour que les filles
puissent jouer puisse faire des échecs
une profession ça je trouve que c'est
plutôt positif après lui fait qui est le
plus de l'appellation tournoi mixte et
on a féminin ça de moi ça me donne pas
envie de regarder le tournoi féminin en
fait parce que une sous-catégorie je
serais beaucoup plus à l'aise s'il y
avait un tournoi mais un tournoi femme
le fait qu'il ya un tournoi mixte ne me
donne pas envie de regarder l'autre ce
que tu as un tournoi qui exclut des gens
et en a un autre qui il ya tout le monde
donc moi j'ai envie de regarder juste eu
lieu il ya tout le monde
c'est comme si avant même temps une
coupe du monde junior tu vois je
regarderai pas
son projet 100% away peut-être même une
presque une cinquantaine en tout donc
ouais c'est une catégorie junior en même
temps ou ou le championnat le
championnat de la région paca tu vois en
même temps que la coupe du monde je
regarderai pas là de la région paca non
plus quoi après c'est avec coupe du
monde hommes et coupe du monde femmes tu
vois ça m'intéresserait plus de savoir
qui gagne chez les femmes un peu ma
logique
de facto le toit mix il va falloir
maintenant il ya des femmes qui ont été
invités pas du tout cas toute façon si
l'appellation mixer que les femmes
peuvent peuvent participer aux qualifs
ailleurs polgar hafaiedh fin était pas
si loin d'être championne du monde à
l'été satyam mondial donc c'est possible
grâce à une poussette de baky way
être petite poucette parce qu'il ya ce
pion dessin qui peut être bizarre et les
pions qui avance le président qui va
jouer la gagne
pure ont une nouvelle fois qu'ils
craquent le sens vraiment pas sûr de lui
puis rooney y a que pour les tués se
détend uniquement fin où ça existe à
échance ans fernand ça existe à tous les
échelons championnat de france même
jeune talent et catégories filles et
garçons c'est à dire peut-être une des
raisons pour lesquelles les filles
jouent moins bien par exemple des
joueuses comme pôle gare ne jouer que en
mixte
battus rooney n'a pas l'air bien il
n'avait pas l'air bien
du coup l'effort soirée dans le mix les
fans force on est dans le féminin
baky je pense qu'il va la jouer un jeu
rooney les deux nouveaux mâts l'otan et
il a déconné je pense enfin il peut la
gagner c'est plutôt piorun qui peut la
perdre
jérôme kiki en panique est aujourd'hui
bas qui va se qualifier pour les quarts
et il attendra magnus un de pied ferme
ouais enjoignent à des catégories filles
mx3
dans le cas
je roule en sueur alors il a dû jouer il
ya dû avoir un bug il doit y avoir des
coups là ce que les pendules était assez
bien réglé jusqu'à maintenant
bon certes y'a un problème de pendule où
il ya un problème de retransmission mais
ça a pu tomber un sa pub choc côté pur
aune là c'est le genre de situation de
rarissimes situation où c'est possible
de tomber autant quand tu te choque
complètement
une erreur de retransmission je vais
regarder
ah non là nul a été signé et je pensais
que ma qu'ils allaient faire poussette
mais il a proposé la drau nul signé bon
après c'était micropousses atteint
c'était micropousses alors que vidic a
battu e du gharb il est alors là ce
n'était pas vraiment le bug du chrono
c'était le temps que la nuls soit
effective sur l'échiquier du coup il
reste quoi elles visitent qualifiait
tabatabai je pense que c'est drôle je
vois pas comment il peut gagner je veux
harira n'y un format du départage ce
sera demain 14h des parties rapides
maintenant un petit tweet
j'ai mon petit tweet
je mets mon petit tweet une petite
seconde avec les tie breaks pour mvl
etienne
bîmes le truc qui parle attendez je vais
je vais aller voir fois parce qu'il
voulait peut-être faire un résumé juste
après une petite seconde
voulait-elle faire un résumé
afin que tu vas un peu regarder les
parties du jour avec vous à 18h et qui
va vous faire un faux cul va peuple
pendant peut pas parler qu'à préparer un
petit récap paix pouze des résultats du
coup je vais remettre de la pub on en a
on a peut-être mis un peu moins de pub
là il faut il faut de la pub
donc je vais mettre deux trucs de pub et
je vais envoyer un raid en fait je vais
faire quelques petits blitz que je vais
envoyer après on aura le résumé paix
pouce de le résumer paix pouce de fab
nom fera pas de résumé pour ses
partisans à résister pas intéressante
j'ai mis la pub on est bien on est bien
on voit les pubs et du coup on va tout
de suite switch on va pas s'embêter on a
vu ce qu'on avait à voir les parties
intéressantes point qui nous intéressait
sont terminés null null carlson nul baky
nul gris tchouk gains visite qualifiée
nul fait d'os martirossian ça va faire
nul car yakine départager ce vide l'air
et shankland qualifiés donc il reste que
ça là mais c'est une forteresse sa femme
il va nous faire le petit résumé donc à
partir de 18h moi je m'en voyez je vais
mettre les petits clips et on va partir
j'attends juste encore une petite minute
pour pouvoir envoyer la deuxième pub ça
on aura un petit coup de prez on est
bien
et on est bien on est bueno
ne bougez pas on va faire la bascule
d'ici quelques secondes alors sympa
d'alphabet from du truc de fou je la
part garder le calme il va regarder avec
vous un peu ce qui s'est passé
maxime ali sur twitter font sens qui
faisait lui même ray fait la bascule ne
bougeait